[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre grande
émission d'actualité parlementaire du
mercredi nous sommes ensemble jusqu'à 17
heures trois heures d'émission est un
temps fort à 15h ne manquez pas les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
au programme cette semaine plusieurs
questions sur la crise migratoire entre
la turquie et la grèce cette situation
qui met l'union européenne à l'épreuve
décryptage réaction avec aujourd'hui
jérôme rabier dans l'hémicycle et steve
jourdain salle des conférences
les retraites acte 2 alors que
l'assemblée a adopté cette nuit la
réforme après l'utilisation par
l'exécutif de 49 3 la balle est
désormais dans le camp du sénat le texte
doit arriver au mois d'avril dans
l'hémicycle mais la chambre haute
réclament un report de 15 jours pour
avoir les conclusions de la conférence
de financement enfin le coronavirus
remet-il en cause notre économie
mondialisée
alors que le scénar interrogatoire
l'exécutif sur les mesures prises deux
santé publique face aux risques
d'épidémies on débat sur ce plateau
dans une demi-heure et n'hésitez pas à
réagir et à commenter cette émission
avec le hashtag qu âgées
et on va tout de suite rejoindre jérôme
rabier dans l'hémicycle du sénat bonjour
jérôme dans une heure maintenant vont
commencer les questions d'actu je le
disais alors comment ça va se passer et
quels sont les thèmes qui émergent
chaque après-midi et bien tam qui dit
actualité chargée d'une séance de
questions au gouvernement qu'il sera
tout autant les retraites
évidemment abordé 1 avec notamment deux
présidents de groupe bruno retailleau et
patrick kanner qui interrogeront le
premier ministre d'abord sur l' usage du
49 3 et sur le calendrier parlementaire
à venir du projet de loi
mais on parlera aussi énormément de la
crise migratoire à la frontière gréco
turque avec pas moins de six questions
sur le sujet alors qu'un conseil de
défense spécial s'est tenue ce matin à
l'elysée jean yves le drian présentera
la position du gouvernement français
et enfin le coronavirus sera aussi très
largement abordés et notamment ses
conséquences sur l'économie française
voilà tam pour le programme merci
beaucoup à geron pour ce menu on
retrouve un petit peu avant 15h et place
à présent un autre débat consacré aux
retraites
l'examen du volet principal de la
réforme a pris fin la nuit dernière à
l'assemblée malgré les tentatives à
droite comme à gauche de s'opposer aux
49 3 mais la bataille parlementaire
n'est pas terminée le sénat doit se
saisir du texte au mois d'avril
ils réclament un délai de 15 jours pour
débattre en ayant les conclusions de la
conférence de financement mais en
attendant les travaux de fouilles ont
commencé ce matin la commission des
affaires sociales a auditionné plusieurs
économistes résumé de cette table ronde
avec oodrive états pour entamer leurs
travaux les sénateurs ont demandé
l'éclairage des économistes sur trois
thèmes bien différent les effets de la
réforme pour l'état et la fonction
publique
ensuite ce qui fonctionne ou pas chez
nos voisins à l'étranger ceux qui ont
déjà mis en place le système à points
est enfin question plus précise antoine
bozio l'inspirateur de la réforme
ils lui ont demandé quels étaient les
décalages avec ses préconisations des
questions bien différentes mais des
réponses qui convergent les économistes
et met d'abord des réserves sur le
système à points et sur son indexation
aujourd'hui c'est
un objet statistiques non identifiés sur
lequel on peut faire de très nombreux
scénarios différents
j'étais critiques pendant une quinzaine
d'années des systèmes à point critique
de la façon dont à l'agirc-arrco des
règles discrétionnaire mal maîtrisée
pouvait avoir des conséquences critique
du fait qu'un système en points
il faut avoir confiance dans la valeur
du point dans leur ligne de mire aussi
les concessions du gouvernement en
décembre sous la pression sociale
notamment l'application de la réforme
aux générations 1975 au lieu de 1963 ce
qui la retarde ce qui pose problème car
les complexités qui est liée à la
multiplication des règles vont continuer
à exister même si leur poids certes va
décroître petit à petit ils pointent
enfin des études d'impact flou qui
renforce le sentiment de méfiance des
français pour un système qui devait être
plus juste sur le papier je pense que
c'est dommageable pour en réalité la
bonne conception d'une réforme qui j'en
reste persuadé aurait pu faire l'objet
d'un beaucoup plus large consensus
le manque d'études d'impact sur les
finances publiques c'est bien ce qui
pose problème aussi à la commission les
sénateurs se sont émus de devoir voter
une réforme sans aucune visibilité et
pour parler de la réforme des retraites
et notamment de la réforme des retraites
au sénat quatre invités sur ce plateau
cathy apourceau poly bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice communiste du pas de calais
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales avec nous également sur ce
plateau rené paul savary jour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur l ère de la morne
vice président de la commission des
affaires sociales et vous êtes
rapporteurs des retraites pour cette
commission également avec nous martin
lévriers bonjour martin léveillé vous
êtes sénateur la république en marge des
yvelines
également membre de la commission des
affaires sociales et enfin avec nos éric
kerrouche bonjour bonjour sénateur
socialiste des landes membre de la
commission des lois
d'abord petit retour sur cette audition
dont on vient d'avoir un aperçu rené
paul savary
avec quelles impressions êtes-vous
ressorti de cette audition parmi les
personnes auditionnées il y avait
notamment et bien antoine bozio l'un des
inspirateurs de la réforme qu'on a
présentée comme telle et puis qui a
expliqué qu'il est aussi
huîtres à des suites mais ma part la
mise en oeuvre oui tout à fait je crois
qu'il ya une déviance par rapport au
projet initial et d'ailleurs monsieur
bosio était sur le concept de faire un
régime universel que pour les salariés
et des indépendants avec toutes les
différences qui peut y avoir n'étaient
pas pris en compte et on voit bien que à
travers les propos de ces trois
économistes
cela confirme nathalie ce que je fais de
ce texte mettant pencher sur ce dossier
depuis un certain nombre de temps qui
fait que derrière il ya un certain
nombre de points qui ne sont pas claires
et que si on veut redonner confiance aux
français va falloir éclaircir ces
problèmes et ça devrait être le travail
du sénat me semble-t-il martin lévriers
plusieurs points ont été soulevés ce
matin notamment et bien on a pu entendre
l'économiste de l' ocde qui a indiqué le
choix et la durée de transition dilue
les effets positifs qui sont attendus de
la réforme à savoir la recherche de
simplification on est parti d'un bon
objectif la simplification et pour lui
on n'arrive pas au bon résultat on est
parti d'un objectif c'est déjà important
l'objectif doit être tenu c'est aussi
très important et il est vrai que le
rallonger dans le temps complexifie
effectivement la chose c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais il faut aussi tenir compte de
la population tenir compte de ce qui
existait et vouloir aller vite sur une
réforme aussi compliquée et qui touche
tout le monde puisque effectivement
comme le disait de rené-paul savary ça
ne touche pas que les salariés demandent
je pense effectivement des ajustements
dont il fallait tenir compte et c'est
pour ça que le premier ministre à
décaler l'âge de l'âge concernés 203
115e justifier ce choix même si on voit
oui il le complexifie mais il faut tenir
compte de la population nous on le voit
en haut des basques ont fait énormément
de débats dans des circonscriptions j'en
ai fait une quinzaine et on le voit bien
ce problème là ce besoin de comprendre
dans le temps c'est vrai que ça a
complexifié
oui ça complexifie mais du coup et bien
à ce que les faits c'est que justement
la population a du mal à comprendre
cette réforme est un certain nombre de
parlementaires aussi cathy apourceau
poly est ce que c'est votre cas
évidemment c'est mon cas oui la
population est d'abord on peut voir le
mouvement qui lie à chaque jour dans les
rues qui à moins qu'il ait vu qu'on voit
dans un certain nombre notamment de
denquête d'opinion
l'opinion reste très familier vous
faites des raveaux râble vous faites
bien de le dire l'opinion
majoritairement 1 reste très défavorable
donc à la réforme des retraites
d'ailleurs ce matin et on a fait
quelques auditions notamment avec renée
paule qui est là puisque nous sommes
dans la commission des affaires sociales
tous tous les gens que nous avons 10
youn et nous parle du flou artistique
donc de cette mission il nous parle du
fait qu'ils n'y comprennent pas grand
chose que beaucoup de questions ont été
posées et que les réponses n'ont pas été
apportées donc voila et puis le
mouvement syndical et le mouvement
social ne s'essouffle pas c'est ce que
je remarque tous les jours et les
kerrouche votre réaction notamment sur
la question de l'étude d'impact ce matin
encore on a entendu un certain nombre
d'économistes qui disent eh bien l'étude
d'impact elle reste très lacunaires
votre réaction au fait que et bien la
demande d' enquête de commission
denquête des socialistes à l'assemblée a
été rejetée elle visait justement
l'étude d'impact bon c'est pas forcément
une surprise
ah non avec la république en marche ce
n'est pas une surprise non je dis c'est
leur pratique habituelle refuser la
discussion refusé qu'il y ait des
échanges
notre collègue disais tout à l'heure il
faut prendre du temps il faut il faut
discuter il faut tellement prendre de
temps que l'on utilise le 49-3 à
l'assemblée nationale il faut également
prendre tant que nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de revenir sur une étude
d'impact dont même le conseil d'état dit
qu'elle est lacunaire
enfin bon non non je veux dire l'heure
on ose tout et voilà c'est la république
en marche
martin lévriers vous ne laissez pas le
temps comme on dira qu'ils patients bien
sûr qu'on laisse le temps puisque ça
fait deux ans et demi qu'on travaille
avec réussi à convaincre et aussi je ne
vous ai pas couper la parole et que est
sorti déjà rapport au mois de juillet le
rapport delevoye qui a été retravaillé
en sus des pages avec les partenaires
sociaux avec des chiffrages je reviens
sur un point qui est quand même
essentiel aussi on parle du flou de la
difficulté c'est terrain mais les
réformes la retraite aujourd'hui le
système d'aujourd'hui ça a été dit par
les économistes ce matin en commission
des affaires sociales c'est aussi un
flou
terrible demandé à l'agirc-arrco de
connaître votre retraite si vous la
prenez dans dix ans c'est impossible
les quelques heures sauf que moi je les
fais de la chanson à 55 ans une
simulation une simulation je sais
combien moi je ne sais pas moi je ne
sais pas et pourtant je gère cargo
depuis le début et on sait bien que ce
système n'est pas équilibré difficile et
donc le système existant empêche aussi
de faire des simulations puisqu'on ne
peut pas calculer sur le moyen terme les
sous-systèmes l'améliorer sans tout
changé on peut arriver à une convergence
c'est déjà parti donc on peut y arriver
ce qui ce qu'il faut savoir pour
répondre à la préoccupation de nos
concitoyens c'est de répondre à leurs
questions quel est leur question quand
on les rencontre c'est à quel âge je
peux partir et avec combien important du
taux plein or dans ce nouveau système un
système est l'otage automatique car est
un contingent le tir est un coup dur aux
on pourra pas leur garantir quoi que ce
soit même par rapport à l'indexation du
poisson pourri 2037 quelles garanties
vous les donner en 2035
donc c'est là que pose un certain nombre
de difficultés
et puis et puis il ya cette déviance qui
a été fait parce que cette réforme elle
part sur deux piliers qui sont pas
établis au départ c'est l'âge de 62 ans
d'une génère un âge pivot parce qu'il
faudra travailler plus longtemps donc on
n'ose pas le dire et on met ça et puis
que d'autre part on veut faire un régime
unique faire rentrer tout le monde dans
le même costume
et forcément c'est pas faisable nous
serions les seuls en france en europe à
avoir un régime unique avec un départ à
62 ans
voilà pourquoi c'est compliqué les
mélanges et parametric et systémique à
rabat on arrive une confusion telle
qu'on aurait pu répondre aux questions
rené paul savary vous venez d'évoquer la
question de la valeur du point
effectivement c'est l'un des grands
points d'interrogation au sein de cette
réforme l'un des économistes ce matin
bien dit il faut avoir des règles sur la
valeur du point afin qu'il ne soit pas
un outil pour manipuler la valeur des
pensions c'est bien lorsque craeynest un
nombre de français
or il est vrai que le gouvernement n'a
pas toujours été très clair sur le sujet
et un extrait qui tourne beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux
c'est le secrétaire d'état lors
emplettes rashevski qui tente
d'expliquer la valeur du point
il était notre invité dans notre
matinale il ya une quinzaine de jours je
vous laisse regarder
le revenu moyen d'activités par tête
sera composé à cette dixième du salaire
moyen par tête pour les salariés de
celui des fonctionnaires autour de 20%
de celui des indépendants hauteur de 10%
c'est un indicateur composite dont on
voit bien que les trois pros
constituante existe déjà
vous dites que la valeur du point ne
baissera pas mais est ce que la valeur
du point à qui ne baissera pas non plus
mais elle ne baisseront pas parce que
c'est un débat que nous avons commission
et la reconnaissons aussi qu'il ya eu
des échanges de fond dans la commission
spéciale c'est un débat que nous avons
eu les valeurs d'achat et de services
sont indexés de la même façon pardon
parce que c'est le matin vous faites par
les techniques moi je sais ce n'est pas
très clair vous désormais que vous dire
si vous voulez on indexe la valeur à
l'achat de la même façon que sur le
service le service et la valeur du point
qu on vous rendra quand vous prendrez
votre retraite natale évrier vous
admettez que bon l'énoncé n'est pas très
clair et on a du mal vraiment à suivre
parce que c'est un sujet technique je
vous la corde mais je vous rappelle que
je reprends le système agirc-arrco
aujourd'hui piloté par les partenaires
sociaux qui connaît le fonctionnement
qui connaît le montant exact de la
revalorisation des salaires qu'on a pu
percevoir il ya vingt ans comment ils
ont été indexés qu'elles sont ce sont
des systèmes assez opaque qui sont
décidés entre eux et qu'ils font souvent
perdre de la retraite donc le système
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas bon avec le
nouveau système il y aura une seule un
seul point pour tout le monde qui sera
le même pour tout le monde et dont le
système de revalorisation sera le même
pour tous katia enfin moi je crois que
et tuèrent philippe s'est pas trompé il
a sorti donc le 49-3 la veille où on
allait discuter de l'article 9 où
justement on allait aborder la valeur du
point et il ne voulait surtout pas
discuter de ce point parce que
évidemment c'est tellement de flou qu'il
n'y comprennent même même plus eux-mêmes
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire comme
réforme
donc on allait discuter il sort le 49-3
entre deux cours novartis est quand même
très inquiétant cette façon de faire un
samedi soir à 17 heures et alors on
allait aborder le lendemain donc la
valeur du point et l'âge pivot et ce
sont des articles sur lequel le
gouvernement est incapable de répondre
et ne veut surtout pas répondre parce
qu'il n'a pas les arguments pour
convaincre les français et les français
qui ronge vous êtes d'accord le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu en quelques
temps de sauter l'obstacle de ces deux
sujets qui sont pourtant majeur au sein
des réformes même mais le problème c'est
que surtout le gouvernement ne sait pas
ce qu'il fait et je pense que c'est pas
tant il y avait qu à suivre la
discussion dans la commission spéciale à
l'assemblée nationale où il y a vraiment
des questions de fond qui ont été posées
par l'ensemble des acteurs
or la majorité et on avait un silence
mutique de la part du gouvernement et de
la présidente et du rapporteur spécial
je ne comprends pas cette situation moi
je veux je veux bien qu'on dise qu'on
peut parler au fond du sujet mais pour
débattre
il faut être deux et là le gouvernement
ne veut pas débattre parce que comme
d'habitude il à la vérité sauf que la
vérité de plaies par en france aux
français et vous l'avez dit depuis
l'activation du 49 3 il y à encore plus
de français qui sont contre cette
réforme et valls en retrait c'est quand
même significatif maintenant lévriers je
voulais c'est répondre mais d'abord on
va faire un petit détour par la salle
des conférences rejoindre steve jours
d'un quartier vous êtes avec le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales le sénateur l'est républicain
alain milon ami alain milon bonjour
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de ces
auditions ce matin est ce qu'elle vous
ont rassuré sur cette réforme des
retraites
c'est une question à laquelle est
difficile de répondre
c'était très très intéressant les trois
personnalités présentes connaissait bien
leur sujet en particulier
monsieur motion ils nous ont dit des
choses passionnantes mais est-ce que ça
m'a rassuré donc sûrement penser qu'elle
est toujours déséquilibrée cette réforme
c'est ce qui nous a été dit ce matin en
plus surtout le fait que plusieurs fois
nous avons posé la question de savoir
est ce qu on connaît le coût de cette
réforme et le coût de la transition et
nous avions en face de nous des
spécialistes économistes qui ne
connaissait pas qu'ils n'avaient pas du
tout l'idée de du coût de la transition
entre le système actuel système futur
donc c'est pas du tout rassurante alors
la première bataille était perdue par
l'opposition hier à l'assemblée
nationale qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant au sénat la guerre continue
contre ce texte
il faudrait demander ça à l'opposition
de gauche
je pense que les leurs à l'assemblée
nationale avait déposé des amendements
mais pas quarante mille 40 miss est pas
acquise et posée qui va se poser qui va
se passer maintenant que le texte arrive
au sénat
qu'est ce qui va se passer on va
l'étudier d'abord vous avez vu que le
président du sénat a demandé que celle
de l'examen de ce texte soit retardé de
quinze jours nous pensons que le
gouvernement n'acceptera pas de retarder
de 15 jours donc on va examiner un texte
alors qu'on n'aura pas encore les
conclusions de la conférence sur le
financement ce qui est évidemment un peu
embêtant pour des gens qui veulent
travailler sérieusement sur un sujet qui
va coûter plusieurs dizaines de
milliards à la france pourquoi selon
vous le gouvernement refuse de reporter
justement cet examen du texte je pense
que parce qu'il est pressé les pressés
d'en finir avec un texte qui de toute
façon il a servent les esprits de tout
le monde actuellement
et parce que c'est un texte qui n'est
pas facile au départ le slogan dire pour
un euro cotisé touchera la même chose
c'est un slogan facile c'est un slogan
populaire après le mettre en application
avec tous les régimes qui se sont
installés depuis maintenant près d'une
centaine d'années ça n'est pas si
évident c'est pas si facile et de ce qui
nous a été dit ce matin c'est que
contrairement à ce qui se dit beaucoup
seront perdant dans la réforme
et qu'est ce que en quelques mots qu'est
ce que la droite va faire ici au sénat
vous allez essayer de ralentir les
débats
non on va essayer de les construire on
va essayer de faire passer des messages
importants de va essayer aussi de faire
en sorte que ce projet de loi qui ne
nous semble pas satisfaisant aux yeux
des françaises et français puissent au
moins avoir la montage d'une bonne
information pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci
beaucoup
steve pour cette interview un la droite
qui serait donc plutôt dans une attitude
de construction de construction de son
propre projet lorsque le texte va
arriver mais d'abord retour sur le 49-3
martin à lévriers bon le 49-3 on le
critique beaucoup quand on est dans
l'opposition on utilise des comptes
n'est dans la majorité mais tout de même
c'est un suscité par exemple des départs
dans vos rangs celui de votre collègue
michel amiel est ce que ça vous vous le
comprenez vous savez très bien que le
départ de michel amiel été actée déjà
avant
il a trois semaines quatre semaines
qu'il avait quitté le groupe donc il
n'avait pas ficher l'avait pas dit parce
que c'est passé il a choisi un virus il
a lui aussi au courant d'un virus fin
bon voilà bon je pense qu'ils avaient
des bonnes raisons de politique
municipale que je peux entendre mais
qu'ils ne viennent pas interférer sur ce
qu on fait aussi du fait que quand même
aussi cette attitude ait pu le braquer
non non non je ne pense pas parce que 43
tout le monde le connaît et aujourd'hui
tous ceux qui s'y opposent non utilisé
une fois l'autre tous sans exception
pourquoi parce que c'est un outil de la
constitution que la constitution c'est
quand même le garant de notre démocratie
on sait tous appuyé dessus on s'appuie
tout sur cette constitution il fait
partie de la constitution alors si on
doit pas utiliser des outils de la
constitution quand il ya de
l'obstruction là je ne comprends plus
rien que pour ça c'est fait aussi pour
ça et bien évidemment que c'était pour
ça quand vous avez 41 mille amendements
j'ai fait un petit calcul rapide il ya
on était à deux semaines plus de deux
semaines de travail au à l'assemblée
nationale y rester von et l article 8 à
peu près et on se fait juste il fallait
il fallait il fallait plus de 20
semaines
à ce rythme là non plus de vingt ans je
viens je finis plus de 20 semaines
uniquement sur ceux sur ce projet là
donc bloquant tous les autres ça fait
deux ans et demi qu'on a pensé qu'à
danser car il fallait pas faire
d'obstruction moi faire de la ses
boutiques sur jusqu'à faire faire de la
sémantique pendant des jours et des
jours sur les amendements de sémantique
non c'était pas sérieux du tout à
l'obsession juste avant les choses juste
rappeler des choses de base le parlement
c'est le lieu du débat des biens fonds
propres devrait désormais pas si vous
les vrais d axa il faut parlementaire ça
c'est du vrai débat
le deuxième poids de l'obstruction
s'agissant de ce texte c'est quand même
incroyable
pourquoi il faut une lecture accélérée
sur ce texte
alors que ça représente accardo dépenses
publiques pourquoi il faut cinq jours
pour étudier l'étude d'impact qui fait
plus de 1000 pages et vous pensez être
sérieux par rapport aux français
maintenant sur le cas sur l'article sur
la tête 49 3 paul reynaud avait une très
bonne définition du 49 3 y lisent et le
49 3 s'impose de soucis d'abord c'est en
contradiction avec l'article 3 de la
constitution qui dit que et bien la
souveraineté nationale s'exerce par le
biais du référendum et par les
représentants du peuple et aussi avec
l'article 34
plaît à l'époque que c'est le parlement
qui vote la loi
alors on peut c'est ce que c'est ce qui
vous fait le record mallet 49 3 et
michel rocker il est et ce qu'elle
partira chez moi monsieur les vrilles
sur escaut mais s'il n'avait pas de
majorité à l'assemblée nationale
et c'est et loire fait les banquiers ce
n'est pas la majorité en 86 vous ne
voulez pas gelé brillé à venir vous vous
ne voulez pas en tant que l'on discute
sur ce texte
c'est regrettable parce que je pense que
comme ça a été dit c'est un texte
essentiel pour les français est coupée
le débat sur ce tag que c'était une
pratique vous mais ce n'est pas que ça
avait été moi d'intervenir quand même
que ne dépassera pas la confusion mais
c'est l'expression même des
préoccupations des français
comment une réforme ceci doit être plus
juste plus lisible où tout le monde doit
s'y retrouver
arrive à mettre massivement les gens
d'entre eux cela et et les mettre dans
la rue il ya bien il ya bien un problème
et le problème est effectivement et les
français l'ont bien se trompe il n'y a
pas la transparence nécessaire c'est
clair juste une anecdote en tant que
rapporteur
je demande à l'état des précisions sur
le financement d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs de solidarité
c'est important plus de solidarité veut
dire que derrière il ya des
bénéficiaires mais avec le système
automatique ça veut dire que d'autres
pour équilibrer le système va travailler
plus longtemps ça mérite qu'on s'y
penche quand même je n'ai pas de réponse
des ministères il va falloir que je me
rende dans bientôt dans quelques jours
directement sur place pour aller
répondre donc cette absence de
transparence nous fait dire que il ya un
flou quoi oui il ya un flou alloudi la
des économistes aussi lisais ce matin on
a le sentiment que l'exécutif a voulu
faire croire qu'il n'y aurait que des
gagnants alors que l'on garde
naturellement keane que cela n'est pas
possible que n'effectuent que
l'eurosystème
ya forcément des gagnants et les
perdants at least la même façon ils ont
dit qu'on avait annoncé tout est fait
des gagnants mais que tout ne se
passerait pas pour les retraites je
pense aux enseignants en particulier si
on parle des enseignants c'est pas la
retraite qui a gagné c'est une
augmentation de salaires la
revalorisation cet équilibre entre les
deux de deux budgets tout à fait
différent vous parliez très gentiment
des agriculteurs allez les voir
moi j'en vois beaucoup là mesdames ans
ils sont très contentes de très forte
parce que vous plaît parce qu'ils n'ont
pas tout quarante ans sur les
agriculteurs les amener là où ça bouge
qui avait refusé d'augmenter la retraite
agricole à 85% du g3
nous les agriculteurs la cour de la haye
souvenez vous du débat mais attendez
oubliez pas bien sûr sur les acteurs
étaient du rapporteur l'augmentation
pour avoir moins pension mais pas du
tout les agriculteurs les profs les
femmes voulaient faire croire que les
femmes vont arrêter grand bénéficiaire
de cette réforme non mais vous rigolez
vous êtes vous leur faire nous est en
train de leur faire perdre les huits
trimestre ce qu'elle avait c'est un jeu
détruits juste aux médiations avec le
gros comme demander de voter pour que
nous puissions avoir une commission d'
enquête justement encore une fois sur
cette étude d'impact parce qu'il n'est
pas possible de partir sur des bases qui
sont fausses et tout le monde s demande
de commission denquête est donc juste
peut-être sur le 49 3 par rapport à ce
que disait le mentor de monsieur
lévriers edouard philippe
le camp du oui évidemment le premier
ministre disait le 49-3 n'a jamais été
une arme destinée à museler l'opposition
c'est une arme destinée à museler la
majorité l'aube touche c'est quand le
gouvernement n'a pas de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale il n'est pas sûr
de faire adopter un texte à l'assemblée
nationale
il sort le 49 3 en août voilà ce que
vous dites est ce que nous dit votre
premier ministre et il sort le 49-3
parce que effectivement il a bien vu
qu'on va demander dans la rue contre le
mans va tenter de se projeter un petit
peu un sûr et bien le débat au sénat qui
se profile pour le mois d'avril
prenez pas le savoir il ya une carte à
jouer peut-être pour les républicains
les républicains qui n'ont pas forcément
été très audible lors du débat à
l'assemblée nationale puisque
l'opposition était largement confisqué
par l'attitude de la france insoumise là
vous allez porter votre contre projet
notamment le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et moi de vous dire
que les républicains me semble-t-il où
étaient audibles ils ont fait un contre
projet shah était clair constructif le
sénat à l'assemblée vous l'admettrez ce
sera peut être vu comme je les emmerde
ce sera plus facile au sénat on s'est
même si nous dépassons animé aujourd'hui
se respecter respecter les arguments au
sénat on a le droit de penser
différemment dans ce pays on a droit de
construire ensemble et il nous
appartiendra véritablement de montrer
aux français quelles sont les
complexités de ce dispositif est montré
qu'en fait c'est parce qu'on nous a
vendu
oui voilà mais malgré cela nous serons
dans un travail qui sera complètement
complémentaires par rapport à celui de
l'assemblée nationale c'est l'essence
même d'une démocratie avec deux chambres
martin léveillé
est ce que pour cela pour avoir ce débat
vous personnellement vous seriez pour le
report de 15 jours du débat comme le
demande gérard larcher depuis le début
de l'année certains dans vos rangs ne
sont pas contraints c'était le cas par
exemple de frédéric marchand qui l'a dit
oui moi il n'ya que très honnêtement sur
ce sujet je n'ai pas vraiment d'avis je
pense qu'on parle si ça peut apaiser de
ce débat depuis deux ans et demi
effectivement je pense qu'il est
important aussi
après ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale de montrer à l'ensemble des
français qu'une chambre est capable
d'avoir un vrai débat de bien travailler
je rejoins complètement ce que dit rené
paul savary
je veux croire et je l'espère vraiment
qu'ici il y aura pas une logique
d'obstruction et d'amendements tous
azimuts qui empêcheront un débat sérieux
parce que le débat saillon la commission
et on travaille les missions se font de
façon remarquable et je crois que c'est
tout à l'honneur du sénat de rehausser
le débat et j'attends ce débat - avec
une grande impatience
pour bien montrer qu'on peut travailler
ce que ce que disait pour la paul savary
même avec nos différences cathy
apourceau poly km la commune
est ce que vous allez déposer autant que
cela a été le cas à l'assemblée
je précise 49 nous allons déposer
beaucoup d'amendements évidemment parce
que nous avons envie d'avoir le débat de
fond le débat aurait pu avoir lieu et je
le redis sur le fond il aurait sur le
fond mais comme à l'assemblée nationale
mais les députés comme le garros n'avait
pas les épaules en règle générale ont
quand même déposé des amendements pour
que l'on puisse avoir le débat c'est
légitime
c'est une des réformes qui engage nos
populations dans l'avenir sur des années
des années c'est normal que nous
voulions avoir le débat de fond nous ne
l'avons pas eue nous l'aurons au sénat
et évidemment je suis moi pour qu'il y
ait parce que on nous dit ici que
beaucoup d'agriculteurs sont plus pour
cette réforme écoutez moi j'ai j'ai
quand même bien l'impression que ce
gouvernement est le seul à pouvoir
prétendre toujours avoir la bonne parole
et bien qu'il fasse à référendum
qu'il fasse un référendum dans les
populations pour voir qui est pour cette
réforme et qui est contre et là les
urnes parleront un référendum qu'est ce
que vous en pensez eric héraud shop et
moi je pense que c'est toujours
c'est toujours une bonne solution parce
que en l'espèce le sujet est crucial
pour l'ensemble de la population
française et je pense pas qu'il faut
avoir peur de la voix du peuple bien
entendu j'entends que c'est compliqué
étant donné la situation dans laquelle
s'est mis l'exécutif et je pense
qu'effectivement il y aura un débat au
sénat
et je crois qu'il sera important parce
que là il ne sera pas possible
effectivement pour la république en
marge de encore une fois m l'étouffoir
sur le débat comme c'est régulièrement
le cas à l'assemblée nationale en ce qui
nous concerne nous avons à peu près
portait un ensemble national environ 700
amendements qu'ils étaient des
amendements de fond et qui ont
d'ailleurs posé des questions
essentielles comme l'ont montré les
interventions de valérie rabault et de
boris vallot et je crois que nous
continuerons dans cette veine parce que
et c'est important
la perspective c'est de montrer tout
simplement que le système tel qu'il est
conçu ne fonctionne pas qu'il est
dangereux et qui est dangereux pour la
plupart des français je me réjouis de ce
débat où on pourra démontrer l'exact
inverse de ce que dit mon confrère où on
montrera que certes c'est un sujet très
technique malheureusement qui
complexifierait l'idée d'un référendum
parce que c'est un sujet très complexe
et très compliqué et notre rôle nous
d'élus c'est justement est de travailler
de deux travaillé énormément pour
simplifier les choses la santé donc je
crois beaucoup à ce débat et je crois
que le sénat sonora de faire un très
beau débat et j'ai vraiment confiance en
soi la route et surtout moins sûr et qui
peut-être vous mettra tous les cadres
d'accord on attend un véritable débat au
mois d'avril
ou peut-être début mais si
éventuellement là la position demandé
par gérard larcher a été retenu mais
pour l'instant cela semble assez
compliqué merci à tous les cadres
d'avoir persisté au débat nous sommes à
une demi heure des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
voyez peut-être ça commence à arriver
dans la salle des conférences dans cette
salle qui jouxte l'hémicycle au
programme des questions cet après-midi
la crise migratoire entre la grèce et la
turquie mais aussi des questions sur la
réforme des retraites
notez aussi d'ailleurs que ce soir à la
demande de gérard larcher et les
sénateurs vont interroger le
gouvernement sur le coronavirus on voit
d'ailleurs s'intéresser aux conséquences
économiques du virus se poser cette
question avec nos invités ce virus
met-il en lumière la dépendance mondiale
à l'égard de la chine remet-il en
quelques sortes en cause la
mondialisation vaste débat
le coran navire is impact en tout cas
déjà les places boursières et la
croissance mondiale fabriquèrent le
coronavirus est il plus dommageable pour
l'économie que pour l'homme la
croissance mondiale pourrait chuter à 2
4% son plus bas niveau depuis la crise
de 2008 selon les prévisions les plus
optimistes de l' ocde en cause notre
dépendance à l'économie chinoise
lusine du monde maillon essentiel des
chaînes d'approvisionnement
que ce soit dans l'automobile que ce
soit dans l'électronique on voit aussi
dans la pharmacie dans un certain nombre
de secteurs manufacturiers et donc ça va
jouer sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement mondiales et donc
sur la production mondiale ça c'est le
choc direct par la production il ya choc
autres notamment pour les pays européens
c'est via le tourisme et notamment le
tourisme chinois
des effets qui pourrait être
démultipliée si l'épidémie venait à se
propager davantage en europe
une épidémie qui met en tout cas en
lumière la fragilité de notre économie
face au poids grandissant de la chine et
pourrait accélérer un processus de
relocalisation de certaines activités
vers l'europe
cela fait maintenant près de trois ans
que nous nous efforçons de relocaliser
un certain nombre de chaînes
industrielles ça prend forcément du
temps mais c'est indispensable
nous l'avons fait par exemple un secteur
automobile avec les batteries
électriques
ça doit être fait et ça sera fait dans
le domaine du médicament ou nous
dépendons beaucoup trop de certains pays
étrangers
y aura-t-il un après coronavirus en
matière de politique économique
la crise sanitaire du coc vide 19
devrait en tout cas amener certains
acteurs à reconsidérer leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement
voilà pour ce sujet de fabien becker et
j'ajoute que nous apprenons que l'italie
ferme toutes ses écoles et ses
universités jusqu'à mi mars toute
l'italie et toutes les écoles et toutes
les universités cet effectif à partir de
maintenant on va débattre en tout cas
des conséquences économiques du corps en
a des vues sur ce plateau avec sophie
primas bonjour vous êtes sénatrice l ère
des yvelines et président de la
commission des affaires économiques
également sur ce plateau jérôme durain
joue bonjour sénateur socialiste de la
saône et loire membre de la commission
des lois et de la délégation sénatoriale
aux entreprises
alors tout d'abord et bien on voit de
façon très claire ce coronavirus il
commence déjà à impacter la croissance
mondiale les résultats prévisibles ocde
a donné lundi ses estimations elle
estime que la crise pourrait faire
tomber la croissance mondiale à 2 4% en
2020 contre 2 9% en 2010 9 sophie primas
ce que cela vous inquiète
ah oui c'est ça commence à devenir
extrêmement inquiétant mais on supputait
avec l'arrêt des activités en chine que
forcément ça allait avoir des
conséquences sur la croissance de la
chine elle même mais aussi sur la la
croissance de tous les pays qui
dépendent de près et de loin de la chine
soit parce que on y exportent des biens
et des services
soit parce qu'on en importent des biens
industriels qui nourrissent notre propre
production industrielle et commerciale
donc les effets commencent à se sentir
ils se sentent en provenance de la chine
mais on va avoir nos propres effets
intrinsèque et probablement qu'on nous
en parlerons dans quelques instants
absolument jérôme durain est ce que cela
montre aujourd'hui aussi que la chine a
une place de plus en plus importante
dans notre économie mondiale c'est ce
qui a été observé en 2003 y avait déjà
eu le strass mais il n'y avait pas du
tout eu le même type d'impact est donc
un certain nombre d'économistes en
inquiète déjà notamment et bien daniel
cohen qui estime qu'il va y avoir un
avant et un après ce qu'on a vu c'est ce
que vous êtes d'accord
oui c'est sans doute lié à
à cette crise sanitaire particulière qui
est celle du corona virus
c'est aussi lui un mouvement qui a
commencé déjà depuis quelques années
mais et la dépendance vis-à-vis de
l'économie chinoise
l'interdépendance des économies
nationales dans la mondialisation
produit déjà des effets pervers
la dépendance dont je vois manière très
très grave avec une certaine acuité dans
la période sur les médicaments sur les
sujets qui sont les plus est plus
sensible mais on voit que la tech est
concerné l'industrie linceul est mobile
les croisiéristes et c'est toute
l'économie mondiale qui remise en cause
en question mais ça a commencé avant le
corps un navire russe oui une première
commerciale s'est même d'environnement
tôt il ya tokyo et puis d'aider des
sujets aussi de de politique économique
nationale qui deviennent un peu plus
isolationniste c'est le 4 up états unis
ckd maudit en inde le break site c'est
un peu le même mouvement
donc on va sans doute encore une
amplification d'un phénomène qui avait
déjà commencé
oui vous êtes d'accord sophie primas
est-ce que cela remet en cause quand
même la mondialisation mais c'est juste
la goutte qui fait déborder le vase
finalement il y avait d'autres éléments
auparavant déjà lors avec du monde c'est
quelque chose qu'on pressent depuis
maintenant des mois et pas dire des
années on voit bien que par exemple
quand on a parlé du rapprochement alstom
siemens était déjà de ça dont on parlait
c'était la capacité pour l'europe de
créer des champions industriels qu'ils
soient des champions européens et qu'ils
puissent faire face au bloc qui puisse
résister à cette interdépendance entre
les blocs économiques cette guerre
commerciale entre les blocs économiques
ce sont des sujets qui nous intéressent
beaucoup aient lieu en ce moment moi je
mène une mission sur le rapprochement
entre les chantiers de l'atlantique et
fincantieri sur les bateaux de croisière
bon voilà qu'on aime
et là la trouille qu'on a en tout cas là
l'inquiétude qu'on a c'est effectivement
le transfert de technologie de savoir
faire vers la chine et du coup une
dépendance totale
voilà donc je pense qu'effectivement ce
coronavirus c'est un révélateur un
révélateur est un révélateur violent
pour le monde politique bien sûr mais
qui s'était déjà saisi du problème mais
aussi pour les français dans notre
quotidien dans la vie quotidienne ils
s'aperçoivent de cela vous l'avez dit
c'est un révélateur sur un sujet en
particulier très marquants celui des
médicaments
prenez ce que dit
bien sept membres de l'académie de
pharmacie marie-christine belleville
elle estime qu'il ya urgence à réduire
notre dépendance à l'égard de ces pays à
rétablir notre souveraineté sanitaires
en particulier pour les médicaments
indispensables tels que les
antibiotiques ou encore les anti
cancéreux jérôme durain on voit ça
touche à des sujets sanitaires essentiel
aujourd'hui oui c'est d'aimer mais il
n'ya pas que sujets sanitaires cette
question la souveraineté elle est posée
depuis plusieurs années vous savez
j'étais un projet d'arnaud montebourg
qui avait parlé de démondialisation et à
l'époque ça faisait beaucoup rire avec
un mépris qui était parfois un petit peu
pénible aujourd'hui on voit que les
choses ont changé et on imagine la vie
bruno ménard par les relocalisations par
exemple et tout le monde y vient et je
pense qu'on ne sera pas franchement en
désaccord sur les sujets avec ce film
aujourd'hui parce que tout le monde a
conscience du fait que la souveraineté
doit s'exercer sur des secteurs
stratégiques
c'est la question des médicaments sur
des secteurs stratégiques que sur la
défense sur l'industrie quand on parle
de roy way nokia sony ericsson
c'est ce sujet là au niveau européen qui
est posée donc la démondialisation ou en
tout cas une part de relocalisation des
activités un rééquilibrage il faut qu'on
ait de tout partout
c'est une forme de rupture avec une
division internationale du travail avec
une hyperspécialisation qui coûte
aujourd'hui dont on voit les effets
négatifs à la télé par don moyé coupés
mais les industries les politiques on a
sous-estimé globalement est généralement
juste la gestion des risques
c'est à dire qu'on est allé vers une
compétitivité prix partout sur la
planète sur le monde et tout d'un coup
on s'aperçoit que ben voilà cette
complicité ppri est là un pendant qu'est
le risque de dépendance que l'on prend
et pour une gaulliste comme moi
évidemment ça pose des questions depuis
longtemps et d'ailleurs qu'on a partagé
que c'est mon nouveau teaser mène par la
relocalisation mais alors ce que sophie
primas la france est suffisamment
attractif pour les relocalisations
qu'est ce qui effraie aujourd'hui les
industriels pour davantage relocalisé à
ce que vous pensez que vraiment le
mouvement est en marche
moi je pense que le mouvement est en
train de se mettre en marche par dont
j'aime pas trop cette expression est en
tout cas voilà est en route cette
réflexion est en route elle doit infuser
dans
les management et dans les dans les
chais léché des grands patrons de
l'industrie française et l'industrie
européenne d'ailleurs parce que c'est
juste une histoire aux français c'est
une histoire européenne
on voit bien que vos l'interdépendance
italiennes françaises espagnoles
allemandes etc
on est on est sur un petit continent
donc il faut qu'on ait cette réflexion
commune
j'ai le sentiment que ça va donner un
sentiment d'urgence sur ces
problématiques la de de gestion de la
concurrence de réflexion sur notre
autonomie notre souveraineté
industrielle je pense que voilà c'est
tous ensemble que là c'est le bon moment
d'y aller
est-ce que vous pensez que ces arguments
peuvent vraiment l'emporter face à bien
ce qui a fait qu'on en est arrivé à
cette situation c'est à dire que la main
d'oeuvre à l'aide abondante a les moins
chers dans certains pays émergents et
considère que c'est quand même aussi ça
qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui on divise
ainsi le travail dans certaines
industries à toulouse y invite les
questions sanitaires les questions
stratégiques les questions
environnementales
le coût de la production les la nature
de la fabrication industrielle et des
process de production qui sont parfois
moins respectueux de l'environnement
ailleurs si la question sociale
moi je suis le président dieu du groupe
d'amitié france bagdad est quand on
visite des ruines là bas on voit qu'il
ya quand même un appel d'air pour que
les choses évoluent depuis le rhin à
plaza donc tous nous y invite et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que le débat
public sur ces sujets c'est plus les
quolibets et les grands éclats de rire
qu'on avait il ya quelques années vous
voulez ériger des frontières on a
compris que les frontières ça ne
marchait pas on le voit bien sur le
confinement en revanche ce qui
fonctionne c'est quelque chose qui est
assez naturel assez de bon sens c'est
consommer local manger local fabriqué
près de chez soi
ce sera pas vrai pour tous les produits
mais rééquilibrer rééquilibrer c'est pas
la fermeture c'est un rééquilibrage et
je pense qu'on va y venir
on y viendra pour des questions
économiques puisque on a quand même 30
milliards de déficit de la balance
commerciale avec la chine
on a aussi un intérêt économique à
ajuster notre rapport aux productions
qui sont faites à l'étranger un
changement de la droite quand même sur
mes racines parce que enfin bon
la droite libérale on a du mal à penser
qu'elle peut vous suivre dans ses
arguments sophie primas alors jamais été
ni nulle très libérale de réflexion mais
partout enfin je vous dirai quel que
soit les groupes politiques aujourd'hui
on est dans cette réflexion de là on est
dans cette réflexion la souveraineté
mais ce que ce que je voulais dire ce
qu'est alors c'est horrible de dire ça
mais ce qui est intéressant dans le
phénomène coronavirus c'est que comme ça
touche les français dans leur vie
quotidienne
en fait ces sujets qui d'habitude il
délaisse ses sujets deviennent des
sujets citoyens deviennent des sujets
qui vous impact à titre personnel et du
coup qui génère la réflexion de est ce
que finalement j'ai pas envie de payer
mon aspirine 2 centimes plus cher ou 3
centimes plus cher en étant sûr que j'en
ai quand j'en ai besoin
et que finalement la production elle se
fait peut-être je pas quoi en italie en
allemagne et en france
en tout cas elle est dans un périmètre
où elle sera accessible
je pense que c'est ça qui est en train
d'éclore aujourd'hui et qu'elle
coronavirus malheureusement avec tout
son cortège de craintes économiques
derrière va permettre
voilà ça peut paraître un changement de
modèle si on est un petit peu plus à la
situation aujourd'hui est maintenant
bruno le maire a décrété l'état
d'urgence économique
il veut des mesures de politique
budgétaire il jusqu'à sont nécessaires
pour voulais qu'elles sont nécessaires
jérôme d'hier à aujourd'hui
écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut
amplifier le mouvement de
réindustrialisation dont on a longtemps
dit qu'il était nécessaire et qu'on a eu
du mal à faire entendre
donc si on peut favoriser une politique
industrielle ambitieuse de l'euro la
qualication de sites industriels sur les
secteurs stratégiques mais pas seulement
de façon à se mettre un peu à l'abri de
la concurrence et de la dépendance
vis-à-vis d'eux d'autres pays
je pense que c'est une bonne chose juste
pour me dire sur ce que disait sophie
primas à l'échelle de la mondialisation
on voit quand même que le français moyen
nous sommes tous la française réagit
comme contribuable vis-à-vis des cafards
on va bien qu'ils ont payé des impôts
les autres payent pas comme consommateur
c'est des produits comme citoyen comme
usagers des services publics
donc effectivement ce sujet là il est à
l'ordre du jour de tous nos agendas
politiques
oui un mois sur les sons les mesures
d'état d'urgence puisque enfin les
mesures d'urgence décrété par bruno le
maire il a déclenché les étalement de
charges sociales et fiscales comme ça
avait été le cas pour les gilet jaune
il veut mobiliser la banque publique
d'investissement un bpi france garantir
fortement les prêts que les pme ont
besoin de souscrire pour soutenir leur
trésorerie dans le contexte à ce que ça
ce sont les bonnes et si ce n'est pas
critiquable sont des mesures d'urgence
c'est le seul kit gilet jaune qui avait
été effectivement utilisé l'année
dernière je ne pense pas malheureusement
que ce sera suffisant pas on verra
jusqu'où va cette crise et quelques l
effet là je pense à des secteurs comme
le tourisme l'événementiel et c où tous
le chiffre d'affaires qu'il n'ait pas
fait maintenant qui est perdu est
définitivement perdue on n'est pas dans
le domaine de l'industrie où l'on
repousse des productions des livraisons
des chantiers etc
on est en l2 voilà le chiffre d'affaires
il est perdu définitivement
je pense que au delà de la trésorerie du
mois prochain ou du mois d'avril
il ya des entreprises qui n'arriveront
pas à s'en remettre est ce que vous êtes
de ceux qui pensent que l'europe aussi a
eu un réveil un petit peu tard dit dans
la tardive dans la gestion de cette
crise
il ya eu aussi la van der leyen à lundi
qui s'est exprimée le fmi la banque
mondiale la bce qui ont cherché à
rassurer les marchés mais certains
estiment que tout de même l'europe n'a
pas tout à fait été au rendez vous je
sais pas s'il est utile de tirer
l'ambulance si vous me permettez cette
formule malheureuse
la crise est là nous essayons tous de
nous adapter le moins on a de polémique
le mieux on peut la gérer ensemble il
faut agir pour tous les secteurs
économiques qui sont en détresse et sa
fille prime a raison de dire que dans le
secteur du tourisme notamment
il ya des dépenses qui n'ont pas été
réalisés voir comment on peut être on
peut substituer de la dépense nationale
à dépenses internationales c'est aussi
des actions de promotion qu'on peut
faire et je pense qu'il ya surtout un
travail d'adaptation sur le long terme
ne passons pas de temps vaines
polémiques sur l'immédiat tout est
plutôt regarder comment s'adaptent à 10
ou 15 ans parce que c'est un vrai
travail de fond il faut qu'on s'y
attelle je vais voter pour quelqu'un de
droite
est-ce qu'il faut pas fermer les bourses
pour éviter la wii vous de panique
générale je sais pas
on a perdu 5000 milliards de
capitalisation en deux jours en trois
jours il faut peut-être évité
collectivement cette espèce de folie
économique mondiale qui touchera tout le
monde je ne sais pas
voilà une idée qui me vient mais
peut-être que lé papalia de la droite
elle vient de la droite c'est bien ça
prouve qu'on est plus on est intelligent
et c'est l'intérêt du débat sur les
retraites ou sur deux sujets on échange
on avait plus en plus de mal avant la
défense sur la droite et la gauche sur
ce plateau sur certains sujets on a
l'habitude de travailler ensemble pour
chercher les meilleures solutions en
tout cas pas ce qui me paraît important
suite à ce que vient de dire sa fille
prima c'est quand même que on est aussi
là pour porter un message de confiance
d'éviter une psychose économique social
sanitaire dire que on fait confiance à
notre système sanitaire que sur ces
sujets là il s'agit pas de faire de la
polémique avec le gouvernement
il faut plutôt contribué à aider ceux
qui travaillent qui ont du mal à
travailler qu'ils aient du mal à gagner
leur vie et qu'ils perdent des parts de
marché ou des marchés immédiatement et
puis après on s'adaptera mais pensons
long terme gérons ensemble court terme
et les gens la seconde qui évite la
panique est-ce qu'il peut y avoir quand
même des craintes pour l'économie
européenne qui est une économie déjà
fragilisée on l'a vu par les guerres
commerciales vous l'avez cité notamment
au début de ce débat
oui évidemment on l'appelle la peur
n'évite pas le danger
les périls sont devant nous mais nous
sommes responsables politiques on n'est
pas là pour jeter de l'huile sur le
brasier ou plutôt la poisse et trouver
des solutions c'est sa fille après voir
oui bien sûr qu'il ya des risques à ne
serait-ce que sur l'industrie
l'histoire des pièces détachées qui m'a
qui empêche aujourd'hui certaines usines
de fonctionner si on n'a pas de
production n'a pas devant moi qui ai pas
de réponse aujourd'hui à 95% asiatiques
par exemple par exemple donc évidemment
qu'il ya un péril sur notre industrie il
ya un péril sur un certain nombre de
secteurs économiques est un péril aussi
parce que les le mouvement des tourisme
du tourisme international va plus se
faire ne se fera plus on voit bien les
américains viennent plus dans notre pays
les chinois bas n'en parlons pas donc
voilà donc où il ya des périls évident
et à court terme
voilà donc n'ajoutons pas de la panique
et la panique juste un mot pour conclure
sur cette information que je vous
donnais au début de ce débat les
fermetures des écoles en italie l'un et
l'autre c'est une ça pourrait être une
possibilité me dit on attention ça peut
être une possibilité seulement en italie
et être aussi bon je sais pas quelle est
la logique de tout ça très honnêtement
je prends ça avec beaucoup de prudence
parce que si on ferme les écoles dans le
sud de l'italie alors que menton n'est
pas très loin de l'italie
on est plus près de l'italie du nord
donc je sais pas il faut peut-être une
cohérence un peu nationale je ne connais
pas l'état d'épidémiologie
et deux d'avancé du grenat virus en
italie dont je ne dispose pas des
éléments pour juger de cette cette
décision non pas du tout eh bien merci
beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette discussion
plus casse fin de la phase 1 finalement
on voit qu'il ya bien des points
d'accord qui se dessine avec ce
coronavirus ça peut être aussi un bien
qui émane de ce mal
si beaucoup à tous les élus d'avoir
participé à cette discussion également
dans l'actualité l'europe face à une
vague migratoire la turquie a ouvert ses
frontières vers la grèce aux migrants
dans un contexte de tension qui
s'explique aussi par le conflit syrien
style vous êtes bien que le président de
la commission des lois
philippe bas philippe bas qui d'ailleurs
s'était rendu à lesbos on se le rappelle
dans le cadre des travaux de la
commission des lois il ya quatre ans
mais philippe bas bonjour comment jour
réagir face est à cette nouvelle vague
migratoire parler de nouvelle vague
migratoire ou crise migratoire
d'ailleurs mais bon je crois qu'il faut
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
j'étais avec françois noël buffet qui va
tout à leur poser une question au
gouvernement
notre spécialiste de l'asile et de
l'immigration à lesbos en 2016 868
personnes on était en pleine guerre des
chefs contrôler des parties très
importante du territoire
cette crise a eu des effets dévastateurs
mais a été contenu grâce à un accord
avec la turquie la turquie 7 3 millions
six cent mille réfugiés sur son
territoire
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui n'est pas
une nouvelle crise migratoire lié à une
situation de guerre au proche orient
comme il y a quatre ans c'est une
décision de la turquie qui vient de
subir une attaque militaire au cours de
laquelle 33 soldats turcs ont trouvé la
mort c'est une décision de la turquie de
faire pression sur leurs locaux mars
qu'elle est seule face à la syrie est la
russie et donc si vous voulez
actuellement réagissons avec sang froid
il ya une pression une une forme de
cynisme une instrumentalisation des
réfugiés que la turquie assauts son
territoire et qu'elles laissent partir
alors qu'elle les contenait est donc la
première chose à faire mais d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'a fait hier le commissaire
le responsable européen de la politique
étrangère monsieur borel fils est allé à
ankara capitale de la turquie négocié
avec le gouvernement turc
il faut négocier un nouvel accord avec
la ville est vital de considérer que
quel que soit le cynisme de la turquie
c'est de chez elle que viennent les
réfugiés et non pas de syrie et d'irak
comme il ya quatre ans en plein coeur de
la guerre entre d'esch et les
gouvernements de la région mais emmanuel
macron parle de pleine solidarité avec
la grèce et la bulgarie
il se paye de mots le président est-ce
qu'il faut des mesures concrètes mais il
faut que cette semaine ce en attendant
en effet les européens savent faire leur
unité face au danger pour à la fois
mieux contrôler la frontière terrestre
ce n'est pas le problème le plus grave
mais l'arrivée des migrants sur les îles
grecques qui sont proches des côtes
turques et négocier avec la turquie pour
que ce chantage qu'elle exerce sur une
europe s'arrête et je dois dire que la
situation du proche orient est devenu
extrêmement compliquée depuis plusieurs
années plus encore qu'elle ne l'est
habituellement parce que les américains
sont isolationniste depuis obama ils
sont partis de refuser d'intervenir en
syrie parce que les russes ayant le
champ libre
eux sont là parce que la turquie est
faible face à la russie et qu'elle a
besoin de l'europe
et parce que l'europe est désunie et
qu'elle ne peut donc pas avoir une
politique étrangère qui permettrait
d'obtenir et
résultat sur le flux de réfugiés donc il
y a urgence à ce que l'europe soit unie
comme elle l'avait été au moment où
jacques chirac d'or lors de la grève de
la guerre des américains en irak
il est vital que l'europe soit uni pour
faire face au danger car tout seul on
n'y arrivera pas merci beaucoup monsieur
le sénateur d'avoir répondu à mes
questions nous appris merci beaucoup et
steve pour cette nouvelle interview
alors qu'on est maintenant à une dizaine
de minutes des questions d'actualité on
va continuer à parler des principaux
thèmes débattus
cet après midi alors qu'il ya de plus en
plus de monde qui arrive on le voit
devant l'hémicycle n'est certain nombre
de sénateurs qui sont en train de faire
là à rêver mais aussi gabriela talent
que l'on vient de voir arriver à
l'instant je suis avec anne charlotte
bezina bonjour vous êtes
constitutionnaliste maître de
conférences à l'université de rouen on
va parler ensemble des thèmes qui ont
marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité on en parlait à l'instant
avec philippe bas il ya plusieurs
questions sur mes cette vague migratoire
cette crise migratoire est ce que c'est
une nouvelle épreuve pour l'union
européenne c'est une nouvelle épreuve
fonds l'union européenne en effet on
peut pas dire que c'était totalement
inattendu mais c'était craint dans le
sens où la turquie fait pression l'idée
c'est évidemment de force et par la
méthode la plus dure à se rendre compte
tout en utilisant le vocabulaire
d'erdogan qu'il faut utiliser avec des
pincettes quand même fréquence rendre
compte un petit peu de l'ampleur de la
crise mi gâteau comme migratoires qui
est déjà vécu sur place au niveau turcs
ou reprendre ses propos il femmes
l'europe de prendre sa part du fardeau
c'est ce qu'il dit mais c'est aussi une
façon de faire pression alors qu'il ya
la crise syrienne
effectivement dans le même temps
pression pour une intervention pression
pour une aide est malheureusement déjà
au vu des premières réactions il a déjà
un petit peu réussi son pari dans le
sens où il fait parler de cela et où ils
arrivent à mobiliser l'union européenne
au moins sur cette question alors de là
à savoir si ça va mobiliser
intervention de l'otan ou pas on essaie
encore vraiment trop tôt pour le dire
mais c'est vrai que par rapport au pacs
qui avait été conclu c'est quand même
quelque chose dont l'union européenne
avait déjà pas besoin parce qu'on a
notre part du fardeau qui est quand même
déjà bien là depuis un bon moment
donc cette crise elle va surtout posé
sur la grèce et elle risque franchement
d'être allé désarçonnante au jour le
jour c'est ce que vous jugez est ce que
le prince a pas ou pour vous et bien ce
qui se profile c'est que c'est la grèce
qui seule est en train de faire face la
grèce a déjà plus ou moins lancé son cri
d alarme à l'union européenne en général
en disant qu'elle ne pourrait plus vivre
comme ça donc je pense que sur le long
terme ce n'est pas une situation qui
pourra rester alors que l'on me dise
avant par edouard philippe le premier
ministre qui fait son arrivée un salle
des conférences on le voit également à
côté de marc fesneau le ministre des
relations avec le parlement qui est
également en train de faire son entrée
salle des conférences nous sommes à
quelques minutes du début de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement en irlande bezina c'est un
défi à la fois humanitaire et
sécuritaire qui résonne aussi peut-être
avec le tournoi régalien qui a pris bien
le gouvernement il ya déjà quelques mois
on a entendu de plus en plus emmanuel
macron et bien parler immigration dans
ses interventions
en effet et je crois que c'est une
question qui finalement dépasse
complètement les frontières on parle de
plus en plus de ce retour un certain
nationalisme la crise migratoire est là
pour nous montrer qu' il y à des
questions qui ne pourront pas être
réglés par les seuls états dans une
logique d'état nation que nous avons
vécu jusqu'à présent et c'est vrai que
cette crise migratoire
elle dépasse largement le cadre d'un
seul état des accords internationaux
contre l'europe et on va encore une fois
que les difficultés européen exactement
et le flux ne s'arrête pas donc on a des
accords qui sont conclues à droit
constant et qui finalement ne vont être
obligés d'être actualisés par les faire
finalement il va en tout cas y avoir
plusieurs questions sur ce sujet il va y
avoir des questions sur la réforme des
retraites a alors que l'exécutif a
utilisé le 49-3 il l'avait annoncé
samedi
d'ailleurs on va tout de suite rejoindre
steve jours d'un style vous êtes avec le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
patrick kanner il va ouvrir le bal des
questions avec une question sur les
retraites
oui patrick nerfs bonjour à l'assemblée
la majorité a rejeté la demande et et la
demande émise par le parti socialiste
concernant une commission denquête votre
réaction
je suis furieux je suis furieux parce
que cette commission denquête était
prévue dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon le droit de tirage
d'un groupe d'opposition et on empêche
gounod de positions de travail et on se
demande ce cas le gouvernement a caché
qu'elle commission d' enquête visait à
connaître les moyens qu'ils avaient
utilisé pour bâtir la fameuse étude
d'impact qui a été tellement critiqué
par le conseil d'état donc on parle de
transparence aujourd'hui on parle de
fluidité de l'information est bien la
majorité rem aujourd'hui encore bloqués
un dispositif démocratique
est ce que vous comptez répliqué
notamment ici au sénat oui j'ai demandé
déjà mardi dernier à gérard larcher au
travers de la conférence des présidents
la même commission denquête maintenant
la main appartient à au président du
sénat j'espère que qu'il l'acceptera
puisque ses propres amis politiques
l'awb à l'assemblée avait voté avec les
socialistes pour demander cette
commission denquête encore une fois pour
être transparent vis-à-vis des français
le gouvernement va manifestement refusé
de repousser un examen de ce texte au
sénat qu'est ce que vous en pensez coûté
pour l'instant n'a pas de réponse donc
il ya encore un peu de temps c'est
d'ailleurs là dessus que je poserai ma
question tout à l'heure au premier
ministre donc en dans les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement donc à
va-t-il refusé la main tendue
news que nous voulons simplement toutes
sensibilités confondues c'est de pouvoir
travailler sur la réforme des retraites
en ayant connaissance des conclusions de
la conférence des financements c'est
quand même pas trop demander pour une
autre pour une réforme aussi importante
pour les français
merci beaucoup monsieur canard je vous
laisse pas ce que vous allez poser
effectivement une question dans
l'hémicycle merci c'est à vous tom
oui merci beaucoup steve effectivement
un patrick kanner on va le retrouver
très vite vers 15 heures puisque c'est
lui qui va poser la première question à
toi une bezina votre réaction
justement au fait que l'assemblée
nationale a refusé la demande de
commission d'enquêté de la part du
groupe socialiste - une commission d
enquête sur l'étude d'impact de la
réforme des retraites pour vous c'est
une surprise ou c'était attendu
je pense que c'était attendu
la question qui va falloir se poser
quand même dans les temps qui viennent
c'est le rôle des commissions d'enquêté
on avait vu avec la sphère benalla à
quel point ces commission denquête
peuvent finalement joué un rôle
démocratique assez forts notamment dans
l'information qu'elles vont donner aux
citoyens et sur cette question alors sur
la combinaison commission denquête étude
d'impact je suis pas sûr que ce soit
forcément toujours pertinent étant donné
que normalement l'étude d'impact est
censé être examiné en amont et qui est
déjà même un peu de quel salarié peut
être un embouteillage à risque de
télescopage entre différentes procédures
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon
vecteur mais au moins ça permettait de
mettre au jour le problème du
financement de cette réforme là et aussi
de sa clarté de la transparence qu'en
effet le conseil d'état des pointes et
est par ailleurs et bien on le voit
peut-être qu'il va y avoir cette
commission denquête finalement au sénat
et on voit mal pourquoi et bien le sénat
de droite le refuserait à la gauche pour
le court on retombe un petit peu dans la
commission denquête de la ferme et nahla
c'est à dire que ce que finalement
l'assemblée nationale pour des raisons
majoritaire ne peut pas toujours faire
le sénat lui qui est plus libre
politiquement notamment par rapport à sa
composition peut parfois être amenés à
le faire donc peut-être que là ce qui
n'a pas marché à l'assemblée nationale
fonctionnera au sénat on le voit il ya
un certain nombre de ministres qui sont
en train d'arriver on vient de voir
arriver la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet mais aussi et bien julien de
normandie qui était d'ailleurs en grande
discussion et qui va faire son entrée
dans l'hémicycle tout comme le ministre
de l'éducation nationale que l'on vient
de voir arriver
jean michel blanquer un mot sur est bien
à l'événement parlementaire qui a marqué
la semaine dernière le recours aux 49 3
par l'exécutif le rejet hier et bien des
deux motions de censure de droite comme
de gauche
est ce que pour vous le recours à 49,3
il est il il était inéluctable
le recours aux 49 3 il est classique
dans ces moments dit d'obstruction
parlementaire c'est vrai qu'il ya un peu
d'eux usage de l'article 49 3 il ya
l'article 49 3 qui vient discipline et
des majorités un peu composites ou trop
courte et il ya l'article 49-3 menace
pour discipliner finalement la
discussion en tant que tel truction et
l'obstruction
en effet alors on avait eu par exemple
simple menace de recours aux 49 3 qui
avait pu fonctionner avec l'exemple
raffarin on aurait pu penser que là ça
fonctionne océans se disant finalement
l'opposition va un petit peu modérer ses
essais d'hier et finalement non il est
luc table je sais pas mais attendu en
tout cas sûrement c'était effectivement
pas une surprise même si le moment où il
a été annoncé c'est vraiment une
surprise
un samedi vers 17h merci beaucoup à la
nba n'a vous restez avec nous puisque on
va débriefer cette question d'actualité
d'ici lunaire mais pour l'heure on va
tout de suite à l'essai dans l'hémicycle
où se trouve jérôme radier jérôme on va
parler et bien des programmes de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
et oui tam avec trois sujets sains qui
vont largement dominé cette séance de
questions au gouvernement la réforme des
retraites le coronavirus et la crise
migratoire à la frontière entre la grèce
et la turquie alors steve jourdain viens
d'en parler avec patrick kanner
le départ de cette séance de questions
d'actualité sera consacrée à la réforme
des retraites avec deux questions de
président de groupe celle de patrick anr
mais aussi celle de bruno retailleau
tous les deux comptent poser la question
au premier ministre des questions au
premier ministre d'abord sur
l'utilisation de l'article 49 alinéa 3 à
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi sur le
calendrier parlementaire à venir de la
réforme puisque on le sait gérard
larcher a demandé au gouvernement avec
un report de deux semaines pas encore de
réponse de gouvernement peut-être
edouard philippe pourrait donner des
premiers éléments aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle la cloche va retentir dans
quelques instants vous le savez c'est le
coup d'envoi de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
que gérard larcher est installé je
voulais suivre cette séance de questions
d'actualité
[Musique]
ses ancêtres étaient distribués n'avons
pas reçu d'observation il y en a t'il en
séance je n'en vois point il est donc
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre religion rappelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
ce cas chacun sera attentif au respect
du temps et du respect des uns et des
autres j'ai immédiatement donné la
parole au président patrick kanner pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je vais vous parler de
la réforme des retraites
depuis le début avant même que ne soit
entamer son parcours législatif le
gouvernement enchaîné les faux pas des
erreurs les coups de menton c'est
peut-être cela l'amateurisme que vous
revendiquez
nous pouvons désormais le dire nous
assistons à un naufrage
un ouvrage sur le fond et sur la forme
aujourd'hui je traiterai de la forme car
actuellement elle nous empêche de
traiter sereinement du fonds on ne peut
pas aborder de cette façon une réforme
systémique d'une ampleur telle qu'elle
engage me sort de la totalité des
français et qui concerne 14 % du produit
intérieur brut
l'argument de l'urgence ne tient pas
quelle urgence y at-il à voter un texte
dont personne ne connaît le financement
la seule urgence et celle du
gouvernement qui essaie de se tirer du
bourbier dans lequel il s'est lui-même
enlisé du bourbier n'est l'enlisement de
l'enlisement n'est la panique alors nous
le voyons la panique s'installe dans vos
rangs elle s'installe quand votre porte
parole affabule en disant que l'urgence
justifie par les élections sénatoriales
de septembre qui empêcherait le
parlement de siéger assez longtemps pour
examiner la réforme
monsieur le premier ministre nous sommes
prêts à siéger en juillet si vous le
décidez
elle s'installe elle s'installe
elle s'installe quand ce matin votre ou
projettent sans fondement arbitrairement
la demande de commission denquête sur la
sincérité de l'étude d'impact demandé
par nos collègues députés du groupe
socialiste et apparentés dans le cadre
de leur droit de tirage
qu'avez-vous à cacher monsieur le
premier ministre ma question est simple
allez vous accepter la main tendue par
le sénat allez-vous accepter notre
proposition en décalant le début de
l'examen de la réforme par le sénat à la
fin de la conférence de financement
allez vous enfin nous laisser travailler
sereinement dans l'intérêt des français
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président caennais remercie pour votre
question qui vous avez eu raison de le
souligner porte plus sur la forme que
sur le fond c'est donc sur cette
question de la forme et de la procédure
que je vais vous répondre
sur la forme d'abord vous évoquez la
façon dont le texte arrivera au sénat
le moment où il arrivera au sénat les
deux motions de censure qui ont été
déposées hier à l'assemblée
pardon dimanche à l'assemblée nationale
ont été repoussés hier par deux votes
distincts le texte est donc considéré
comme adopté est adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale
aux termes des dispositions de l'article
49 alinéa 3 je sais que vous n'avez pas
de problème de principe avec l'article
49 alinéa 3 je le sais je le sais car de
la même façon que vous êtes extrêmement
attentif à ce que je dis est ce que je
fais je suis extrêmement attentif à ce
que vous avez dit est ce que vous avez
fait et j'ai bien noté qu'il vous est
arrivé membre d'un gouvernement d'avoir
recours comme ce gouvernement aux
dispositions de l'article 49 alinéa 3
donc ça n'est pas une question de
principe
j'en ai bien conscience le texte est je
vous remercie d'ailleurs de le signaler
car parfois parfois nos concitoyens ne
le saisisse pas de cette façon
l'adoption par l'assemblée nationale en
application des dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 ne vient pas
mettre un terme à l'examen parlementaire
de ce texte
et vous avez raison de souligner
monsieur le président je vous remercie
de souligner car ça permet à moi aussi
de m'en faire l'écho est de dire que oui
ce texte enrichi compléter modifié par
rapport au texte initial qui avait été
déposé par le gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale et qui prend en compte un très
grand nombre d'amendements qui avait été
déposé ce texte sera soumis au sénat
mais vous verrez monsieur le sénateur il
ya plus de 400 amendements qui ont été
pris en compte
il est donc assez largement réussi je ne
vais pas vous faire là
tout de suite des 400 amendements qui
ont été intégrées parce que sinon le
temps que je suis en train de dépasser
serait vraiment beaucoup trop long mais
vous aurez l'occasion de le voir à
l'occasion de l'examen par le sénat de
ce texte un mot pour aller sur la
question du calendrier que vous avez
fixé le calendrier que j'ai précisé très
tôt c'est un calendrier qui prévoit
l'adoption définitive de ce projet de
loi avant l'été
pourquoi avant l'été pourquoi avant
l'été pour une raison très simple c'est
que nous avons voulu que la réforme
entre en vigueur le 1er janvier 2022 et
que entre le 1er janvier 2022 pour tous
ceux qui rentreront sur le marché du
travail
pour la première fois à 18 ans au 1er
janvier 2022 et le 1er janvier 2022 pour
des dispositions qui constituent des
progrès sociaux notamment des avantages
nouveau offert aux françaises et aux
français
et c'est comme ça et si nous voulons que
le dispositif entre en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2022
eh bien il faut que nous ayons le temps
après l'adoption définitive de mettre en
place la totalité du dispositif car vous
savez parfaitement monsieur le président
caennais
vous savez parfaitement monsieur le
président caennais que voter une loi ça
n'est pas créée en pratique le système
qui a été autorisé par la loi il faudra
donc prendre le temps de faire sa vie en
général d'ailleurs les désagréments
qu'ils résultent parfois de décisions
législatives souvent généreuse mais dont
on ne voit pas encore exactement la
façon dont on va les mettre en oeuvre
il nous faudra donc entre l'adoption du
projet de loi et le 1er janvier 2022
mettre en place l'ensemble des
instruments nécessaires à la bonne au
bon fonctionnement et à la bonne mise en
oeuvre du dispositif
nous voulons donc nous voulons donc que
le dispositif soit adopté avant l'été
2020 c'est ce que j'ai indiqué
publiquement dès le début le président
du ces dames a adressé un courrier qui
traitent du même sujet que celui que
vous évoquez j'ai eu l'occasion de lui
dire à l'occasion d'un contact
téléphonique monsieur le président cela
vous m'autorisez à faire état de ce
contact téléphonique jugeant vous en
remercie
c'est merci le téléphone mais les yeux
dans les yeux
[Musique]
et à une époque
à une époque où les contacts physiques
sont plus compliquées cette formule 1
tendresse me touche également monsieur
le président bref tout ça pour dire
monsieur le président caennais que nous
voulons faire en sorte que ce projet de
loi soit adopté avant l'été
j'ai indiqué au ministre des relations
avec le parlement qu'il lui appartenait
de se rapprocher du président du sénat
pour voir dans quelles conditions nous
étions en mesure à la fois de faire en
sorte que la discussion parlementaire au
sénat s'effectue comme nous l'espérons
tous dans d'excellentes conditions et de
garantir que l'objectif que je me suis
fixé d'une adoption avant l'été soit
atteint cette discussion a lieu dans les
heures dans les jours qui viennent
avec évidemment toute la qualité des
relations que nous entretenons avec le
président du sénat je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à notre collègue colette
mélot pour le groupe les indépendants
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre
la propagation du coronavirus est
imposée en quelques semaines comme la
préoccupation majeure des français alors
que le virus était encore récemment
cantonné à la chine
on compte désormais plus de 200 cas sur
le territoire national mondialisation
oblige
l'épidémie est devenu global mais au
delà des aspects sanitaires qui demeure
à juste titre la préoccupation
principale du gouvernement
c'est l'économie mondiale qui risque de
se gripper
vous avez annoncé qu'un ralentissement
de la croissance mondiale serait
inévitable de son côté l' ocde a mis en
garde contre une récession pour de
nombreux pays dont notamment la france
et sainte certains partenaires européens
cela s'explique par l'effet domino qui
affecte les chaînes de production
mondialisé
de nombreuses usines chinoises ont été
mises sous cloche ce qui soulève
d'importantes difficultés
d'approvisionnement pour notre industrie
pour nos entreprises de services la
baisse de fréquentation est déjà
sensible dans les secteurs du tourisme
de l'hôtellerie et de l'événementiel
cette épidémie nous fait aussi prendre
conscience de notre forte dépendance
économique dans certains secteurs
stratégiques notamment dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
nous ne voulons pas être alarmiste mais
nous devons répondre aux préoccupations
de nos entreprises et tout
particulièrement de nos pme
madame la ministre trois parties pour
une question quelle stratégie le
gouvernement at il retenu pour limiter
en france les conséquences économiques
de cette épidémie pour toutes nos
entreprises
comment l'articuler avec une action
concertée au niveau européen
en fait sachant qu'en ralentissement de
la croissance se remettant en question
les prévisions
quel impact prévoyez-vous pour nos
finances publiques
pour vous répondre la parole est à mme
agnès pannier rue nash et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances pranab la ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice mello vous avez
raison de dire que cette crise du qoran
au virus va avoir un impact sur
l'économie à ce stade il est difficile
de l'évaluer et je veux ici redire que
certains chiffres parfois un peu
fantaisistes circulent ce que nous
savons c'est que l'impact limité à la
chine et de 0.12 pub sur notre économie
et que pour le reste notre engagement au
niveau du gouvernement et en particulier
de bruno le maire et deux mois et de
limiter cet impact sur l'économie
française en prenant toutes les mesures
permettant notamment de redonner de la
trésorerie aux pme et aux entreprises de
taille intermédiaire qui seraient
touchés que faisons nous nous avons
réuni le 21 février dernier l'ensemble
des secteurs d'activités notamment
personnellement toutes les filières
industrielles pour faire le point sur ce
qui aujourd'hui peser sur leur situation
et sur leur activité les entreprises qui
sont exposées à la chine les entreprises
qui perdent des clients en france faute
de demande et les entreprises qui
peuvent voir leur chaîne de production
perturbée parce que ils attendent des
livraisons venant de près deux pays
aujourd'hui impact et il n'y a pas que
la chine il ya la corée il y a le japon
il y à l'italie autant de situations on
peut avoir quelques jours peut-être une
semaine 1 une suspension production
les mesures que nous avons prises elles
sont très concrètes report des échéances
sociales et fiscales à la demande des
entreprises touchées possibilité de
faire valoir la force majeure dans les
contrats avec l'état et demande et je
profite puisque je suis au sénat demande
aux collectivités locales d'adapter la
même stratégie demande de donneurs
d'ordres de faire preuve de
bienveillance par rapport à leurs
sous-traitants sur les mêmes situations
afin de ne pas rajouter
des pénalités à des entreprises qui
seraient sous pression facilitation des
heures supplémentaires pour celle qui
enfin réceptionne leurs pièces et
doivent activer leur production
inversement financement du chômage
partiel et travail pour faire en sorte
que ces périodes de chômage partiel
puissent également être mise à profit
pour de la formation professionnelle
voilà ce que nous faisons très
concrètement maintenant et en
coordination avec le g7 et l'union
européenne pour des mesures qui seront
prêts encore 30 secondes pour 10 e
mesures qui seront alignés ensemble un
sous forme des jo de roo merci merci
monsieur
la parole est au président bruno
retailleau pour le groupe est
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
ça devait être la mère de toutes les
réformes c'est du moins ce que nous
avait promis le président de la
république emmanuel macron de piles
olympe
mais voilà la rentrée de cette réforme
dans l'atmosphère a été terriblement
dégrisante pas une seule et a pas un
seul étage sans un ratage les deux
première année studieuse de monsieur
delevoye pour rien l'avis du conseil
d'état cruel le débat à l'assemblée
nationale
escamoté escamoté parce que l'essentiel
de la discussion sur le financement se
tenait dans une enceinte parallèle et
pour finir un article 49 3 décidé
délibéré au sein d'un conseil des
ministres convoqué en grande pompe pour
discuter de la crise sanitaire
vous allez me dire c'est une habileté
moi je vous réponds c'est une maladresse
monsieur le premier ministre débattre de
la réforme des retraites sans en
connaître le financement
c'est se moquer des français c'est
pourtant c'est pourtant ce que vous
pourriez faire si vous refusez la main
tendue du président du sénat j'ai
entendu moi aussi la question du
président caennais il ya quelque chose
que je ne comprends pas vous n'avez
cessé de repousser les dates
d'application de la réforme jusqu'en
2047 alors pourquoi chipoter vous sûr
que quinze jours qui nous permettrait
d'augmenter la qualité de l'examen du
sénat
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président
retailleau passé de 42 système de
retraite avec leurs règles avec leur
originalité avec leurs déséquilibres
parfois pas toujours mais parfois avec
leurs contraintes pour créer un système
universel par répartition et par points
c'est évidemment quelque chose de
difficile et complexe et en vérité
monsieur le président retailleau je n'ai
jamais caché jamais caché que la tâche
serait rude où tu en es et nous le
savons tous au delà des au delà des
positions que l'on peut légitimement
avoir sur est-ce qu'on est pour un
système universel ou contre ce qu'on est
pour un système par répartition on
compterait ce qu'on est pour un système
par points comptent nous savons tous que
travailler sur 42 système existant pour
les amener à un système universel qui
prime et les transitions
professionnelles sans perte de droit qui
permet de faire en sorte que la
solidarité de la nation s'exprime sur
l'ensemble des actifs et de ceux qui
l'ont été et qui bénéficie aujourd'hui
d'une retraite c'est un exercice
redoutable
nous avons donc pris le temps de
travailler c'est vrai et certains
peut-être pas vous monsieur le président
retailleau mais certains nous disaient
dans toute cette phase préalable que
cela prenait trop de temps vous vous en
souvenez peut-être c'est ce que je dis
monsieur retail pas vous mais je l' ai
entendu et parfois pas loin de vous mais
je les ai entendus mais il fallait bien
travaillé regarder quelles étaient les
options susceptibles d'être retenus
quels étaient les problèmes qui ne
manqueraient pas de se poser pour
pouvoir
petit à petit construire une réforme
globale
le texte a été présenté au mois de
décembre et j'ai indiqué c'est vrai que
je souhaitais qu'il puisse entrer pardon
qu'il soit adopté avant l'été 2020 de
façon à pouvoir entrer en application le
1er janvier 2022 car vous savez
parfaitement monsieur le président
retailleau vous avez j'en suis certain
déjà regardé ce texte déjà étudié ce
texte qu'il rentre en application le 1er
janvier
2022 pour un certain nombre de ces
dispositions puis on prend le 1er
janvier 2025 pour d'autres de ses
dispositions et que c'est vrai les
périodes de transition que nous avons
voulu progressive à juste titre à mon
avis mais nous aurons l'occasion d'en
parler vont jusqu'à 2037 ou 2047
néanmoins le texte entre en application
dans un certain nombre de ces
dispositions à partir du 1er janvier
la discussion de ce texte en commission
spéciale puis dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas été
possible
pas du tout monsieur le président
retailleau parce que les dispositions
financières que vous évoquez n'aurait
pas été contenues dans le texte parce
que une partie de l'opposition pas
toutes les oppositions d'ailleurs pas
tout mais une partie des oppositions a
délibérément choisi est d'ailleurs
délibérément assumer d'entrer dans une
stratégie d'obstruction de discussions
infinies sur des sujets qui étaient à
l'importance évidemment considérable
puisque vous le savez plusieurs milliers
d'amendements porté sur la question
essentielle de savoir s'il fallait
privilégier dans la rédaction du texte
chaque année ou annuellement analogue ou
similaires eu égard ou considérant ou
linverse parce qu'évidemment tout cela
permet de faire avancer le débat et donc
c'est vrai j'ai eu recours à une arme
non constitutionnelle parfaitement
classique exceptionnel c'est vrai mais
utiliser 88 x avant moi
88 x avant moi je suis le 80 la 89e
utilisation ceux qui disent coup de
force pour un article crée dès la
constitution de 1958 88 coups de force
quand même on imagine mal
et contrairement à ce qui a été dit mais
vous êtes un constitutionnaliste
exerçait contrairement à ce qu'on a dit
le 49 3 est parfois utilisée pour faire
face à ces situations d'obstruction j'ai
un certain nombre de précédentes est
peut-être les avez-vous également
je pense par exemple à ce qui avait été
fait par le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin en 2003 s'agissant du mode de
scrutin aux élections régionales je suis
sûr qu'ici tout le monde s'en souvient
nous avons donc décidé d'utiliser les
dispositions de l'article 49 3 nous
l'assumons de motion de censure ont été
déposées elles ont été repoussées
hier et le texte va donc arriver au
sénat j'ai dit tout à l'heure quelle
était ma disposition d'esprit pour
pouvoir travailler avec le président du
sénat sur la bonne organisation du débat
mais je redis
parce que c'est un engagement que j'ai
pris et que je veux tenir
j'ai dit que je souhaitais que le texte
puisse être adoptée avant l'été de façon
à ce que les mesures à prendre et elles
sont nombreuses après l'adoption du
texte soient prises de façon à ce que la
réforme entre en vigueur le 1er janvier
nous aurons l'occasion monsieur le
président retailleau de discuter de
l'ensemble des détails de l'ensemble des
éléments d'architecturé peut-être même
des principes qui fondent et qui
explique ce texte est d'une certaine
façon j'ai hâte de pouvoir le faire
parce que c'est un sujet passionnant et
parce que les questions qui restent
ouvertes et il en reste qui sont
ouvertes bien entendu mérite un débat
approfondi
je suis certain que nous pourrons la
voir ensemble merci monsieur le
président au caillou 15 jours nous vous
demandons monsieur le premier ministre
et c'est faux pour des millions de
français la date d'application c'est au
moins 2037 vous ne réformez pas vous
déformez notre modèle social
je le dis devant les collègues hisser au
sénat de la république ce que vous
apprêtez à faire ce n'est pas moderniser
notre sécurité sociale c'est a créé une
insécurité sociale pour des millions de
français qui seront perdants vous
baisserez les pensions vous allez vous
apprêtez à créer une sécurité sociale à
deux vitesses pour la majorité des
français d'un côté et pour ceux qui
gagnent plus de 3 plafond de la sécurité
sociale de l'autre j'ai un souvenir qui
est sans doute aussi le vôtre en mémoire
un souvenir brûlant celui de l'extrême
solitude de l'exécutif face aux idées de
conclure je suis sûr que ce souvenir
vous entre qu'il vous habite et bien je
ne crois pas aujourd'hui quelles leçons
vous en avez tiré je ne crois pas
précisément qu'une poignée d'hommes de
femmes sur un pacte social aussi
important puisse décider seul et contre
tous de l'avenir de millions de français
merci la parole est à notre collègue
olivier cigolotti pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
vendredi dernier le président erdogan a
pris la décision d'ouvrir les frontières
de son pays aux exilés en route vers
l'union européenne
violant ainsi les accords de genève
concluant 2016 la turquie qui accueille
près de 4 millions de migrants sur son
sol affirme ne pas être en mesure de
faire face à un nouvel afflux de
réfugiés syriens affluent d'ailleurs
provoqué par ses propres offensive
militaire en syrie à travers l'opération
bouclier de printemps dans la région
d'idlib
ankara a également accusé l'union
européenne d'avoir failli à ses
obligations
notre notamment financières découlant
des accords de 2016
il semble toutefois que nous ayons nous
même fourni cette arme au président
erdogan en le laissant libre de s'en
servir à tout moment contre l'europe
c'est bel et bien du chantage durant le
week-end c'est plus de 24000 tentatives
d'entrées illégales qui ont été évités
et pratiquement 200 personnes qui ont
été arrêtées selon le gouvernement grec
de fait de vives tensions ont éclaté
avec les gardes frontière plusieurs
embarcations pneumatiques transportant
des migrants sont également arrivés sur
les îles de la mer egée où les
populations locales ont violemment
tenter les empêcher de débarquer la
situation est explosive et peuvent
facilement dégénérer
l'union européenne certes s'est
rapidement mobilisée frontex a déployé
des renforts à la frontière gréco turque
et à activer la procédure de mise à
disposition de moyens par les états
membres
de plus hier la présidente de la
commission ursula von der leyen a promis
à la grèce toute l'aide nécessaire et
notamment 700 millions d'euros dont la
moitié sera mise à disposition
immédiatement pour gérer cette vague
migratoire
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple l'europe est-elle prête à faire
face à une nouvelle crise
j et comment le gouvernement entend
qu'il agir pour apaiser ces tensions
je vous remercie pour vos répandre la
parole communistes de l'europe des
affaires étrangères dans l'est le drian
de la parole monsieur monsieur monsieur
le sénateur gigolo t il y a plusieurs
questions sur ce sujet qui sont posées
par plusieurs de vos collègues donc je
vais je vous demande de bien prendre en
compte les différents de réponse que je
vais faire au fur et à mesure pour qu'il
y ait une réponse complète
d'abord pour vous dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que la crise que
connaît actuellement le nord-ouest de la
syrie est dramatique
on va vers un véritable cataclysme dans
le nord-ouest de la syrie
cette crise a une cause qu'il faut
identifier
c'est la rupture des accords de sotchi
ces accords prévoyaient qu'il y ait dans
la zone dite libre 3 millions
d'habitants u ne soit considérée comme
une zone de désescalade pour que les
groupes terroristes nombreux qui sont
puisse être démantelée que la population
puisse y vivent normalement même s'il
s'agit pour une bonne partie de réfugiés
cet accord là était rompu or c'était la
turquie qui en avait la responsabilité
d'où la situation conflictuelle parce
que le régime a décidé une reconquête
territoriales qui fait qu'il y a
conflits armés encore en ce moment entre
les forces turques présentes dans cette
zone en syrie et les forces du régime
cela entraîne une véritable catastrophe
humanitaire dans la zone
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir et cela a
entraîné un comportement inacceptable de
la part de la turquie qui pour remédier
à ce conflit là à la fois pour des
usages internes et externes a décidé
d'instrumentaliser les migrants qui se
trouvaient depuis longtemps sur son
propre territoire
pour faire pression sur l'union
européenne cette attitude là est
inacceptable cette prise d'otage puisque
c'en est une
n'est pas n'est pas pas acceptable et
doit être combattu les initiatives que
nous prenons l son double d'une part
agir auprès de la russie pour on ne
revit
à sotchi et je pense que la rencontre
entre le président ado gagnent le
président poutine qui va avoir lieu
permettra peut-être d'abord arriver à ce
résultat et et d'autre part de marquer
mais je le dirai tout à l'heure notre
totale solidarité avec la grèce pour la
question et la parole est un truc
collègue julien bargeton pour le groupe
de la république en marche
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse également aux ministres de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
l'europe est aujourd'hui confronté de
plein fouet à une réaction en chaîne qui
a commencé à être liban syrie en passant
par ankara et moscou pour arriver à
lesbos depuis plusieurs jours près de
treize mille réfugiés venus de turquie
traverse la méditerranée en direction de
la grèce
cette crise est un nouveau test pour
l'union européenne
nous n'avons plus l'audace d'exister
nous alertent bernard guetta notre
collègue au parlement européen
dans une récente tribune et de continuer
l'inaction aussi à un prix cette crise
défi à la fois l'espace et le temps
l'espace car le vent est devenu une
épreuve de vérité pour l'europe le temps
car la crise des réfugiés de 2015 n'a
jamais été résolu la solidarité entre
états européens a été mise à mal
le mécanisme de répartition des migrants
est restée lettre morte
et aujourd'hui la stratégie européenne
de gestion migratoire avec la turquie se
solde par un échec
il est toujours choquant de faire des
femmes d'enfants et d'hommes des
instruments de politique internationale
nous le savons depuis corps depuis quand
l'être humain est toujours une fin en
soi et jamais un moyen
il en va de la responsabilité du
président erdogan militairement bloqué
au nord de la syrie où est stationné
l'armée turque depuis l'offensive qu'il
avait lui-même lancé il ya quelques mois
et que nous avions tous condamné
aujourd'hui il n'hésite pas à demander
cyniquement du soutien auprès de ses
alliés européens de l'otan demande de
soutien qui se muer en un chantage
inadmissible inacceptable
le président de la république a exprimé
sa pleine solidarité avec la grèce et la
bulgarie
il a clairement indiqué que la france
participerait aux efforts européens dans
le but de protéger nos frontières
notamment auprès de l'agencé frontex ce
matin un conseil des ministres de
l'intérieur de l'union européenne s'est
tenue
pour faire le point sur la situation
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
informer de l'état d'esprit européen
face à cette crise inédite et rappelé la
position de notre diplôme diplomatie à
berck à me le disait je me révolte donc
nous sommes il est temps que l'europe se
lève et se révolte face à cette crise
migratoire merci beaucoup pour répandre
la parole est aux ministres de l'europe
les affaires étrangères et la parole
monsieur le sénateur je les dis déjà il
y a un instant mais je vous le redis
avec force la france est totalement
solidaire de la grèce dans cette affaire
elle est totalement solidaire de la
grèce d'abord pour des raisons
humanitaires
ensuite pas pour des raisons politiques
parce que ce qui se passe en grèce nous
concerne tous
puisque nous sommes tous au sein de
l'espace schengen je voudrais d'ailleurs
relevé mais vous l'avez noté que la
pression migratoire qui est aujourd'hui
aux portes de l'europe aux portes de la
grèce un peu de la bulgarie un peu de
chypre cette pression migratoire elle
est organisée
elle est organisée par le régime du
président erdogan pour constituer un
élément de chantage à l'égard de l'union
européenne l'union européenne ne cédera
pas ce chantage nous avons convenu avec
la turquie un accord en mars 2016 qui
garantissait des financements importants
à l'égard de la turquie en échange d'une
gestion difficile certes des réfugiés
venus de la crise syrienne antérieures 6
milliards d'euros ont déjà été engagés
la moitié a été versée donc nous
attendons de la turquie qu'elle
remplisse elle même ses engagements que
nous mêmes nous avons respecté que nous
continuerons à respecter
alors maintenant vous avez noté que nous
avons décidé d'organiser cet après midi
cet après midi une réunion des ministres
de l'intérieur de l'union européenne
demain je me rendrai à zagreb avec mes
collègues européens pour envisager
ensemble comment est-ce que l'on peut
concrètement aider la grèce aujourd'hui
dans cette situation particulièrement
difficile et je pense que nous aurons
une unanimité à la fois pour valoriser
l'opération frontex pour mettre les
moyens à disposition et pour aider une
terme en ce pays à faire face à ses
difficultés merci la parole est à notre
collègue eric gold pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale au lendemain de la
diffusion d'un rapport de l'inspection
générale de l'éducation nationale
nous sommes souvent sollicités par les
conseils d'administration des collèges
et des lycées sur la baisse des
dotations horaires globales qui
définissent le nombre d'heures de cours
que les établissements peuvent dispenser
dans le puy de dôme par exemple
plusieurs lycées ou collèges vont
connaître une baisse de la dotation
horaire globale malgré des effectifs
stables 16 heures en moins sont en
majorité des heures d'autonomie qui
servent à financer les enseignements
facultatifs mais aussi les dédoublements
de classes et les échanges entre les
élèves de filières générales et ceux du
lys ne cède pas ou encore
l'accompagnement au choix de
l'orientation ainsi une baisse de la
dotation horaire globale
c'est moins de choix dans les options -
d'accompagnement personnalisé voir des
classes surchargées
c'est une dégradation des conditions
d'enseignement pour les professeurs des
conditions d'apprentissage pour les
élèves
cette problématique est d'autant plus
marquée dans certaines zones éloignées
des métropoles
d'une part en terme d'égalité des
chances les élèves accueillis dans les
établissements ruraux vivent souvent une
école - inclusive avec moins
d'enseignements spécialisés et moins
d'options
d'autre part l'éloignement avec les
métropoles empêche les élèves de se
tourner vers des établissements
dispensant des options qui ne figure pas
dans leur compte tenu d'une offre
culturelle moins dense dans ces
territoires l'école est un vecteur
majeur d'ouverture sur le monde
enfin une offre éducative de qualité
attire les familles
il est donc à craindre que la baisse de
moyens attribués à ces établissements ne
vienne aggraver la perte d'attractivité
de certains territoires
monsieur le ministre 42 % des élèves de
zones rurales ont le sentiment de ne pas
avoir assez d'informations pour
s'orienter
cette donnée tout celle que je viens
d'évoquer doivent nous inciter à prendre
davantage en compte les spécificités des
établissements ruraux dont les
difficultés s'aggravent avec la baisse
des dotations horaires globales
vous avez récemment affirmé que les
défis que rencontre le milieu rural
appelle un volontarisme politique et
sociétale fort
et avait reconnu des inégalités fortes
entrées les bureaux et citadins dès le
collège
quelles mesures sont donc envisagées
pour cofrac tueur sociale et
territoriale ne viennent pas s'ajouter
une fracture éducative
je vous remercie tous pour vous répondre
la parole et au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse jean michel
blanquer vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur eric gold
votre question est évidemment très
importante sur un sujet dont je parle
fréquemment au sénat celui de l'école et
de des collèges et des lycées en milieu
rural il est évident que c'est une très
grande priorité devant avoir des
stratégies quantitatives et qualitatives
sur une telle question sur l'aspect
quantitatif on pourrait croire en vous
écoutant qu'il y aurait quelque chose à
défavorable qui se jouerait pour l'école
rurale voulait collège rural où le lycée
rural aujourd'hui en france ça n'est pas
le cas pour vous donner un seul chiffre
il y à 7000 élèves en moins en milieu
rural depuis trois ans et nous créons à
la rentrée prochaine plus de 250 postes
dans les 45 départements les plus ruraux
le pour prendre le département du puy de
dôme que vous connaissez bien
aujourd'hui le taux d'encadrement en
collège et 30% supérieur à la moyenne
nationale donc il n'y a pas un problème
quantitatif aujourd'hui le problème est
d'avoir une stratégie qualitative pour
rendre l'école le collège et le lycée
beaucoup plus attractif et pour avoir
des stratégies correspondant aux
problèmes que vous mentionnez vous avez
mentionné par exemple la question de
l'offre culturelle
vous avez mentionné la question de
l'orientation je voudrais donner deux
exemples
en réponse à votre à votre question sur
ces points sur le sur la partie de
l'offre culturelle nous avons un plan
bibliothèque et un plan numérique qui
dans les deux cas sont en en soutien des
collectivités pour l'équipement en
livrer l'équipement informatique
notamment des écoles mais aussi des
collèges et puis il s'agissant de
l'orientation en lien avec les régions
de toutes les régions de france
il ya aujourd'hui une nouvelle politique
d'orientation qui est particulièrement
destiné aux collèges et aux lycées
ruraux pour en effet remédier aux
problèmes que vous posez c'est à mes
yeux un sujet d'unité nationale et je l'
ai dit à plusieurs reprises
ça doit se traduire par des stratégies
département par département c'est le
sens de ce que nous avons fait avec le
sénateur durant deux comme travail pour
avoir des contrats départementaux de
ruralité qui nous permettent non
seulement de garantir des postes ce qui
est un point important bien entendu mais
non seulement au travers de ce
garantie des postes garantir un bon taux
d'encadrement mais surtout avoir cette
stratégie qualitative dont je parlais
pour lesquels bien entendu nous serons
forcément d'accord parce que oui nous
devons soutenir les écoles les collèges
et les lycées en milieu rural je vous
remercie
mais si la parole est à notre collègue
alain meister benbassa bon le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole pour deux
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères mes
chers collègues depuis décembre 2019
comme vous le savez un drame se déroule
à idlib en syrie
mécontent de ne pas obtenir le soutien
des leaders européens lors de ces
frappes dans la région le président r
doha vient d'ouvrir ses frontières pour
laisser passer au mépris de leur
sécurité et de leur dignité
des milliers de migrants se trouvant sur
son sol déterminé à rejoindre l'europe
l'union européenne est responsable de
cette situation
ayant elle-même fourni à la turquie les
outils de rétorsion que celle ci utilise
contre elle au lieu de prendre notre
part de l'accueil de ces populations en
grande détresse
nous avons monnayer en 2016 notre
tranquillité migratoires avec monsieur
erdogan lui laissant la charge de 3,6
millions de migrants en échange de 6
milliards d'euros et de notre silence
sur l'oppression de nos alliés kurdes
aujourd'hui le flux migratoires se fait
massive l'union laisse la bulgarie et la
grèce
if alpha seul et de la pire façon alors
qu'elles ont besoin d'une aide
financière et logistique immédiate
monsieur le ministre la france est elle
susceptible de mettre sur pied avec
d'autres états membres de l'union
européenne un plan solide et ambitieux
de répartition des migrants afin de les
accueillir dignement et sans délai seul
voeu
et antidote aux déchaînements de
l'extrême droite raciste et xénophobe
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
ministres de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères monsieur le drian avait la
parole oui madame la sénatrice j'ai
commencé à répondre à cette question
tout à l'heure je voudrais simplement
attirer l'attention du sénat sur la
situation humanitaire qui existe
aujourd'hui dans la zone dite libre en
vous rappelant auparavant puisque vous
avez dit que le président de gan avait
déclaré ses frontières ouvertes
je vous rappelle mais vous le savez et
on le constatera encore demain à la
réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne
les frontières de la grèce et donc de
l'espace schengen elles sont fermées et
nous ferons en sorte qu'elle reste fermé
que les choses soient claires mais pour
je voudrais appeler l'attention du sénat
sur la situation en libye puisque
parfois on ne mesure pas bien ce qui s'y
passe il y a dans sept régions trois
millions d'habitants
sur les 3 millions d'habitants il yal la
moitié de réfugiés d'où vient-il des
zones dites de désescalade qui ont été
instaurées au fur et à mesure de la re
conquête territoriale par les forces de
bachar el-assad en syrie
et lorsqu'il y avait une zone qui était
en compte par la force par le régime de
bachar el-assad ont transportés par cars
les habitants tous les habitants dans la
zone dite libre eonia venait aussi tous
les groupes terroristes ce qui fait
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
dans cette zone aujourd'hui sur les 3
millions d'habitants vous avez un
million et demi de réfugiés qui ne
passeront pas en turquie puisque la
frontière là l evam enfermé et qui sont
dans un état de dénuement de détresse
considérables et qui aujourd'hui sont en
train de se déplacer une deuxième fois
car vu l'offensive du régime de bachar
el-assad vers le sud
il remonte vers la frontière turque et
donc beaucoup d'habitants sont pour
l'heure deuxièmes fois réfugiés et
déplacés
avec le froid la faim des épidémies la
recrudescence des violences contre les
femmes et des filles à tel point que le
secrétaire général des nations unies a
demandé qu'une enquête soit faite pour
condamner les frappes aériennes
délibérer sur des objectifs civils que
soient les hôpitaux ou les écoles et que
cela pourrait constituer si c'est
suffisamment documenté ce que nous
allons soit que nous allons nous atteler
d'un sas règles éventuellement reconnu
comme crime de guerre
voilà quelle est la réalité de la
situation et en matière humanitaire la
france et l'union européenne sont au
rendez vous de ces populations s'est
réfugié là ce ne sont pas ceux dont vous
parlais tout à l'heure
cela ils ont été organisées et mobilisé
par le président erdogan pour faire
pression sur l'europe
benbassa quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre vous vous n'avez
pas répondu à ma question est ce que
l'europe se prépare à mettre en place un
programme d'accueil avec répartition
dans l'ensemble de l'europe de ces
migrants qui viennent tâter aux portes
de delà de la grèce et de la bulgarie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
françois noël buffet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président pardon ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur en 2015 l'europe a laissé
dans un premier temps l'italie et la
grèce faire face à cette crise
migratoire issue de la guerre du levant
il a fallu attendre plusieurs mois pour
qu'elle décide afin de pallier son
impréparation et s'adonne anticipation
qu'elles signent un accord avec la
turquie
moyennant finances cela a été rappelé le
6 milliards d'euros pour qu'une partie
des réfugiés soit contenue sur le
territoire turc
aujourd'hui la situation de la grèce est
à nouveau la grèce directement est à
nouveau sous pression
certes dans des proportions moins dans
tous les cas pour l'instant mais
l'origine et la cause n'est pas tout à
fait la même la france est prise comme
l'europe dans un chantage du régime turc
pour d'autres histoires et d'autres
affaire malheureuse que le ministre
vient de rappeler pour autant monsieur
le ministre
qu'allez vous faire quelle va être la
voix de la france dans les jours qui
viennent dans les heures qui viennent à
la fois pour assurer et renforcer la
protection des frontières extérieures
mais aussi en matière de politique
migratoire européenne
on veut répandre la parole et or les
listes de l'europe des affaires
étrangères non monsieur lunesse
pardonnez moi monsieur le ministre la
parole monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur françois noël buffet donc vous
m'interrogez donc sur la position qui va
être celle de la france compte tenu de
la crise migratoires que nous
connaissons actuellement
et je vais vous répondre d'abord à court
terme si vous me le permettez puis aussi
à moyen terme
évidemment d'abord à court terme vous
rappeler que depuis l'automne 2010 9
la grèce connaît sur les îles une
arrivée de migrants qui a augmenté déjà
par rapport à ce qu'elles étaient
précédemment la france dans ce cadre là
notamment dans le cadre des politiques
menées par l'union européenne est venue
renforcer le dispositif frontex et de la
même façon nous sommes venus renforcer
la capacité de traitement des demandes
d'asile
de la grèce je me suis d'ailleurs moi
même rendu en grèce en janvier dernier
et j'ai rencontré mon homologue pour
discuter de ces questions
au même titre donc que le ministre de
l'intérieur avait discuté avec son
homologue concernant la situation
actuelle
il y à un conseil des ministres de
l'intérieur qui se tient en ce moment
qui va se tenir à 17h sur ces sujets
puisque la grèce a demandé la solidarité
des autres pays européens des autres
états membres et donc le conseil va se
tenir tout à l'heure évidemment que la
politique de la france est le ministre
le de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères l'a rappelé évidemment que la
politique de la france aura une
politique de solidarité et que dans le
cadre de ce conseil nous allons examiner
les moyens de venir renforcer frontex
dans le contrôle des frontières grecques
au même titre donc que nous allons
examiner les différentes demandes de la
grèce mais notre position c'est
évidemment celle de la solidarité
à plus long terme monsieur le sénateur à
plus long terme je vous renvoie ce que
au débat que nous avions eue sur la
politique migratoire en septembre à
l'automne dernier à la fois à
l'assemblée et au sénat où nous avons
annoncé que nous portions aussi une
politique de réformes de l'asile
ambitieuse et nous faisons une tournée
des capitales européennes avec amélie de
montchanin nous allons poursuivre cette
tournée pour essayer d'obtenir un
meilleur contrôle à nos frontières mais
surtout un meilleur traitement des
demandes d'asile à nos frontières
pouvoir de façon à pouvoir reconduire en
conclut vite ceux qui ne sont pas en
besoin de protection et accueillir ceux
qui sont besoin de protection et cette
politique nous la portons avec la
secrétaire d'état avec beaucoup de
conviction merci monsieur monsieur
buffet j'entends bien ce que dit le
ministre mais cela fait longtemps que
sur les bancs de cette assemblée
et de ce côté de cet hémicycle nous
avons plaidé depuis longtemps d'abord
pour une pio politiques migratoires
européennes une protection clair de nos
frontières avec des moyens lourds mis à
disposition de notre de nos territoires
la deuxième chose sur une politique de
l'asile européenne qui soit enfin
efficace et qui ne soit pas anticipé
n'est pas laissée au jour le jour
et puis enfin le dernier sujet peut-être
le plus important
comment anticiper aujourd'hui et
préparer le retour de ce qu'ils sont
fugier dans les différents pays du monde
sur leur pays d'origine
y at il une stratégie là dessus merci la
parole est à notre collègue laurence
rossignol pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain j'avais la parole merci
monsieur le président il y a juste une
semaine presque heure pour heure nous
apprenions que deux cas de corona virus
avait été détecté dans l'oise dès le
premier décès dès ce jour le directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé
et le préfet ont pris toutes les mesures
de protection et de prévention
nécessaires et je tiens à saluer ici
leur réactivité leur sens des
responsabilités et leur disponibilité
auprès des élus locaux
à tel point qu'ils sont aujourd'hui tous
les deux confiné aujourd'hui nous
comptons 65,4 contamination dans l'oise
la base aérienne de creil en compte dix
à elles seules à ma connaissance deux
personnels civils sont hospitalisés vous
comprendrez donc que dans l'oise la base
aérienne de creil
dekraai la baie à 110 soit vu comme
l'épicentre du de l'épidémie j'ai pris
connaissance des éléments très
détaillées fournies par le ministère des
armées sur les conditions sanitaires du
vol de rapatriement des français de
roanne et selon la ministère des armées
il n'y a aucun lien entre ce vol et la
contamination
cependant l'équipage de l'estérel était
composée d'environ 10 personnes et il y
à chaque jour 2500 personnes qui entrent
travail circulent manche sur la base
erin comme vous le savez le patient zéro
dans l'oise n'a toujours pas été
identifié ma question est la suivante
comment le commandant de la base
aérienne de creil peut-il affirmer de
manière aussi péremptoire et aussi
définitif qu'il l'a fait que je cite le
patient zéro n'est pas chez nous c'est à
dire n'est pas à la baie à 110 de creil
ce qu'aucune autre collectivité humaine
dans la même situation d'autres fr
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame geneviève darrieussecq secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre des armées
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vous poser une question qui
est revenu en boucle depuis une semaine
effectivement sur la potentielle
transmission du virus dans l'oise par la
base de creil ce qu'on peut affirmer
madame la sénatrice c'est que les
militaires de l'escadron estérel qui se
sont rendus à one pour rapatrier des
français ont été on ne peut toutes les
mesures qui étaient indiqués ne sont pas
sortis de l'appareil en chine sont
revenus ont été mis à l'isolément chez
eux n'ont présenté aucun symptôme que
toutes les personnes rapatriées n'ont
présenté aucun symptôme et que tous les
personnels du service de santé des
armées qui était dans ce vol qui ne font
pas partie de la base de creil n'ont
présenté aucun symptôme donc nous
pouvons affirmer que le patient zéro ne
fait pas partie de ce vol ensuite le
patient zéro
peut-être un patient de l'oise en
général peut-être un patient qui a été
en contact
enfin pu être en contact avec quelqu'un
de la base aérienne de l'oise de creil
ce qui est certain c'est que le
commandant a pris des mesures très
fortes
d'abord une équipe d'épidémiologistes
est venu sur place depuis une semaine
ensuite il a limité pour limiter le
risque d'expansion du virus
toutes les sorties inutile il a limité
l'activité de la base et fait en sorte
de prendre toutes les mesures
préconisées par le ministère de la santé
donc les choses ont été faites à creil
il y a des cas sur la base aérienne de
creil
mais rien ne dit que ces cas sont les
patients 0 rien ne dit que ces cas n'ont
pas été infectés à l'extérieur
l'épidémiologie est une science complexe
surtout dans ce contexte de fort
déplacement de fort brassage de
population et je crois qu'il ne faut pas
mettre l'anathème sur un lieu où toutes
les précautions ont été prises et qu'il
faudrait simplement continuer les
enquêtes par rossignol
rien ne dit en effet que la base
aérienne soit l'origine du foyer mais
rien ne dit non plus qu'elle ne l'est
pas les conséquences dans la population
c'est que sur le bassin creillois quatre
communes aujourd'hui ont vu toutes leurs
écoles fermées il n'y a pas un seul cas
de contamination dans aucune de ces
communes
tous les cas de contamination sont sur
la base aérienne de creil seule l'armée
peut investiguer sur son propre
territoire
les conséquences pour la population
civile sont importantes et je continue
de penser que les propos du commandant
de la base qui disait nous n'avons rien
à voir avec le patient zéro était
hasardeuse et audacieux merci la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue robert
del picchia pour le groupe l'est
républicain président mesdames et
cheminées mais chaque collègue ma
question s'adresse aux ministres
affaires européennes et étrangères
monsieur le brillant j'ai un peu embêté
parce que une bonne pédagogie c'est la
répétition monsieur bancaire ne va pas
me contredire mais où poser encore des
questions sur la turquie et la grèce et
monsieur erdogan sait mettre en doute un
peu vos compétences d'expliquer la
situation vous l'avez très bien fait
pendant les questions précédentes et je
vous en remercie
alors tout le monde a bien compris les
réponses mais on a quand même on est
dans une situation celui mais que va
faire l'union européenne
combien ça va nous coûter encore on a
déjà payé 3 milliards et quelques
comment on va arrêter cela maintenant
monsieur ministre pour arrêter cette
situation
peut-être revenir aux fondamentaux est
ce que il ne faut pas se poser la
question de lancer un appel solennel à
la turquie mais aussi à la russie parce
que finalement à l'origine ces
bombardements comme un i d'ibm
ça a provoqué cette situation vous devez
bien d'accord là dessus alors que peut
faire l'union européenne si ce n'est
lancé un appel très sérieux à la turquie
et à la russie pour essayer de se mettre
d'accord là dessus parce que vous avez
raison les problèmes humanitaires sont
de plus en plus nombreux ils n'arrivent
pas à trouver d'autres solutions
alors c'est vrai monsieur morel et
ankara il va revenir vous voir pour vous
expliquer à zagreb
les résultats de ses entretiens avec
monsieur erdogan
je sais pas si ça va aboutir à quelque
chose mais il faut sortir de cette
situation et peut-être que au fond c'est
là il faut trouver une solution avec la
turquie et la russie pour essayer oui je
sais bien c'est pas facile mais ces
votes on vous fait confiance monsieur
nice merci de votre réponse pour vous
répondre
paroles et au mini les affaires
étrangères de l'europe
j'ai avec le g avec le sénateur del
picchia une conversation ininterrompue
depuis plusieurs années sur la question
turque
je vais compléter mes propos puisque
vous me permettez de le faire nous nous
avons avec la turquie plusieurs sujets
de contentieux lourds y compris récent
plusieurs sujets d'irritation le dernier
étant le non respect de l'accord de 2016
avec l'union européenne qui se produit
sous nos yeux mais il y a eu récemment
la question du nord-est syriens ou
finalement l'initiative turco a remis en
cause notre manière d'appréhender la
sécurité dans cette région de la syrie
il y a eu il y a toujours les actions
turques en méditerranée orientale où nos
engagements sont opposés il y as en
libye les actions que vous connaissez
les ruptures de l'embargo décidé par
nations unies par l'armée turque qui
acheminent en turquie en libye par dans
des forces syriennes ce qu'on appelle
des proxy qui viennent d'ailleurs
souvent de la région d'idlib
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure et puis sur
le temps j'en parlerai dans un instant
l'ambigüité demeure
nous avons aussi sur la question des
libertés
des divergences majeures et puis
l'instrumentalisation des migrants ne
pas n'est pas acceptable
mais nous sommes dans un mètre dans la
même alliance voilà le sujet et donc je
pense que c'est un piquet à queue il
nous faudra avoir rapidement avec la
turquie une grande explication lourdes
franche public pour savoir de quel côté
est l'un de quel côté l'autre et là où
nos intérêts sont communs et dire tout
cela fortement sinon on ne s'en sortira
pas je rejoins votre propos d'ouverture
lors de votre question nous devons avoir
avec ce pays
une discussion exigeante l'actualité
nous l'imposent
ça n'empêche pas les discussions avec le
président poutine que le président
macron à uva avoir encore dans les
heures qui viennent
mais cet impératif là me paraît
essentiel parce que nous avons quand
même un point commun la lutte contre le
terrorisme
je rage rage et pas le temps de dire
tout à l'heure que dans la zone dite
libre
vous avez beaucoup de groupes
terroristes y compris des shs y compris
des combattants étrangers y compris des
français combattants étrangers ce del
picchia quelques secondes ministre merci
pour ces propos est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas réfléchir à une solution politique
imposée entre guillemets en syrie à
travers le nude ou autre merci la parole
est à notre collègue jacques le nay pour
le groupe de l'union centre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'état auprès de monsieur
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances monsieur le ministre bruno le
maire vendredi dernier a déclaré l'état
considère le coronavirus comme un cas de
force majeure dans les contrats qui
lient l'état et ses partenaires
cela me paraît une bonne mesure pourquoi
ne pas appliquer cette disposition
contrats conclus entre les collectivités
territoriales et leurs partenaires et
plus globalement quid du secteur privé
alors que le marché pétrolier et gagner
par la panique alors que l' ocde prévoit
une véritable chute libre de la
croissance mondiale les conséquences
négatives du coronavirus sauve notre
économie nationale paraissent
inéluctables
monsieur le ministre bruno le maire a
annoncé hier des mesures relatifs à
l'étalement du paiement des cotisations
sociales et impôts
mais cela suffira-t-il vous venez dans
votre réponse à notre collègue à notre
collègue colette mélot rappeler ces
points dans notre droit
la secrétaire d'état le cas de force
majeure est reconnu comme un événement
imprévisible et irrésistible
or ce facteurs imprévisibles ne
s'applique pas dans le cas présent du
corona virus qui sévit depuis plusieurs
mois ce flou autour de la notion de cas
de force majeure en l'état actuel du
droit place nos entreprises face à un
risque imminent du nine exécutions de
contrats risques pour lesquels ils
n'auront aucune garantie d'être assurée
transport tourisme culture restauration
hôtellerie
voilà les secteurs qui en subissent déjà
des conséquences en cas de fort
ralentissement de l'économie nationale
ces dernières n'auront pas les moyens
d'assumer dans les mois à venir les
charges qui leur racontent aussi ma
question est la suivante quelle mesure
comptez-vous mettre en place pour les
accompagner n'est-il pas nécessaire
d'envisager un élargissement du cas de
force majeure à toutes les violations
contractuelles et ce afin d'éviter une
future récession financière touchant
l'ensemble de nos secteurs d'activités
vous répondre la parole est à mme madame
la secrétaire d'état
vallouise de l'économie et des finances
avait la parole le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le nez vous poser au fond trois
questions la première l et autour du cas
de force majeure que pourrait
reconnaître l'état pour le compte de
contrats privés
l'état peut le faire dans le cadre des
contrats qu'il a directement avec des
acteurs du privé il l'a fait vous l'avez
souligné et je crois que ça a beaucoup
rassuré les entreprises avec lesquelles
nous avons une relation
en revanche il n'est pas possible à
l'état de prendre la décision à la place
des collectivités locales comme vous le
savez je sais que vous êtes très
soucieux de la libre administration des
collectivités locales mais je ne doute
pas qu'elles le feront également en âme
et conscience dans les jours qui
viennent
nous avons envoyé à l'ensemble des
associations de collectivités locales un
courrier en ce sens s'agissant des
relations contractuelles entre acteurs
privés
il n'appartient pas à l'état de
s'immiscer dans ses relations en
revanche nous avons d'ores et déjà
anticipé puisque nous avons demandé à
chaque filière de faire preuve de
bienveillance dans les relations
donneurs d'ordre et sous traitants et de
nous alerter
si des difficultés pouvaient se faire
jour nous avons également activer la
médiation des entreprises de façon à ce
qu'elle intervienne d'entre dans les
conflits qui pourraient intervenir entre
des entreprises
plus largement je ne vais pas revenir
sur l'ensemble des mesures que nous
avons d'ores et déjà prises je veux
juste rappeler un chiffre lorsque nous
parlons de report d'échéances fiscales
et sociales et que nous l'avons fait
l'année dernière c'est 400 millions
d'euros qui ont été réinjectés dans
l'économie pour dans le cadre de la
crise des gilet jaune donc je crois que
c'est une mesure qui est puissante et
nous regardons effectivement aujourd'hui
l'opportunité de faire comme l'italie
c'est à dire de rendre cette mesure plus
automatique
que l'objectif est de faire en sorte que
les entreprises se concentrent sur leur
chiffre d'affaires sur leurs
problématiques opérationnelles et ne
perdent pas de temps sur ces aspects
plus administratif je vous remercie
merci la parole était notre collègue
jérôme bascher pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président hamza laisser visiter chers
collègues la question s'adresse à
monsieur véran doit être confiné et donc
et ça va s'adresser à monsieur taquet
mais plus généralement à tous les
ministres qui se sentent concernés dans
la lutte contre le coc vide 19 et ce qui
ne manquera pas d'être une épidémie j'y
associe évidemment mes collègues de
l'oise du mort vivant ou et de la haute
savoie qui vont être concernés par la
question
l'oise un quotidien titre les rues se
vident la désorganisation et la wii
quoi qu'en ait dit le gouvernement
pendant un mois et demi il y avait un
préparation à avoir cette crise quoi que
vous en ayez dit nous le vivons chaque
jour dans l'oise où on improvise qu' une
fermeture d'école de faire venir telle
ou telle classe je veux comme exemple
les masques qui ont été dits on les
libère 15 millions de masques ça a été
répété ils sont disponibles pour les
professions médicales depuis hier car
dans cette pseudo préparation vous avez
oublié les premiers de cordée et les
premiers de cordée ce sont les médecins
libéraux
les hospitaliers les infirmiers les
pompiers
les visiteurs d pad les visiteurs à
domicile et cela ne sont pas là mais ma
question
elle va être un peu différent c'est que
demain il ya des élections municipales
il y aura d'autres
premier de cordée les élus que ferez
vous pour protéger ceux qui tiendront
les bureaux municipaux
envisagez-vous de reporter les élections
municipales
pour vous répondre
la parole est aux secrétaires d'état je
le rendu neige sur le ministre monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur je vais
répondre très précisément à votre
question sur les élections municipales
avant ça je ne peux évidemment pas vous
laisser dire vous laissez le parler
d'une impréparation de la crise que nous
vivons de l'épidémie comme lyon je peux
pas vous laisser parler d'une
impréparation
j'ai moi même d'ailleurs dès la sortie
du conseil de défense appelée la plupart
des élus de l'oise pour leur expliquer
les mesures que nous avions prises dans
la plus grande transparence
peut-être que jamais une crise n'aura
été géré dans la transparence que nous
connaissons je crois qu'il ne faut pas
rompre des consensus sur ces sujets là
il ya des consensus qui intéresse la
nation tout entière et vous portez la
responsabilité monsieur le sénateur
d'avoir rompu ce consensus concernant
concernant les élections
concernant les élections municipales il
ya d'abord l'état du droit vous le savez
que la date des élections municipales
est fixé dans la loi et c'est prévu
généralement en mars est un décret qui
fixe cette date et le report ne pourrait
être possible que dans les limites du
mois de mars mais est donc pour reporter
les élections municipales il faudrait de
toute façon une loi mais au-delà de cela
au-delà de cela ce qui importe c'est la
situation sanitaire est le fait de se
rendre dans un bureau de vote
est ce que il y à un risque sanitaire en
l'état de la connaissance que nous avons
du virus il n'y a pas de risque à se
rendre dans un bureau de vote où les
personnes votent de manière très
espacées comme vous le savez il ya
généralement un mètre avant dans une
file donc il n'y a pas de risques
sanitaires identifiés à ce stade
de sorte qu'il n'est évidemment pas
envisager de reporter les élections
municipales cette décision n'est
absolument pas à l'ordre du jour
évidemment évidemment que nous aurons
des discussions avec les associations
d'élus pour discuter des mesures
éventuelles mesures prophylactiques
qu'il faudrait prendre pour que les
élections se déroulent tout à fait notre
normalement ce qui est le souhait du
gouvernement je peux vous le confirmer
monsieur le sénateur en déplorant à
nouveau en conclusion les propos que
vous avez tenus qui sont parlants reçu
le sénateur mais qui sont par rapport à
l'engagement
hank et celui de l'ensemble de
l'appareil sanitaire français de
l'ensemble de l'appareil administratif
français de l'ensemble du gouvernement
contre les propos indignes
monsieur vachon
monsieur le ministre on va pas parler
d'un dignité nous nous sommes sur le
terrain comme vous le préfet fait le
travail est d'ailleurs contaminé preuve
qu'on n'a pas fait assez pour les
premiers de cordée
quand vous dites ça vous inquiétez pas
la démocratie
vous venez de répondre et je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre nous y
sommes attentifs quant à la crise ne
vous inquiétez pas le parlement
contrôlera bien une mission d enquête ce
qui sera passée merci la parole est à
notre collègue bernard bruit pour le
groupe de la république en marche
vous avez la parole merci merci monsieur
le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre en octobre dernier
vous avez présenté la stratégie
nationale de prévention et de protection
de l'enfance je salue chaleureusement
cette initiative car vous avez su placer
comme une priorité nationale la
protection de l'enfance en y allouant
des crédits conséquents
une première enveloppe annuelle
supplémentaire de 80 millions d'euros
sera déployée dès cette année et des
crédits complémentaires devraient suivre
en 2021 et en 2022
bilan de santé obligatoire prévention
des risques de maltraitance et autres
actions peuvent être amplifiés
grâce à ces crédits je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de mettre ainsi un
coup de projecteur vers les plus
fragiles de nos concitoyens les enfants
en danger ou maltraités que ce soit au
sein de leur famille ou dans certaines
structures d'accueil un récent reportage
à secouer d'ailleurs nombre de
téléspectateurs et d'élus sur la prise
en charge de ces enfants
mais si l'état marque sa volonté d'agir
avec le déploiement de budget
supplémentaires évoqués ce sont les
départements qui ont en charge cette
compétence de la protection de l'enfance
je profite de cette prise de parole pour
saluer le travail remarquable et si
difficile des professionnels qui
interviennent parfois dans des
conditions dégradées pour accompagner et
aider ces enfants nos enfants ceux de la
république
c'est d'ailleurs les présidents de
conseils départementaux que vous êtes
naturellement tournés en novembre
dernier pour leur demander s'ils étaient
volontaires pour partager les objectifs
de l'état dans ce domaine
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous faire
un point d'étape sur cette action et
nous indiquer combien de départements
ont effectivement
candidate et combien sont engagés dans
ce processus de contractualisation enfin
envisagez-vous un nouvel appel à
candidature dans les prochains mois pour
vous répondre la parole et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de la
solidarité de la santé monsieur taquet
vous avez la parole
ce ministre
n'entendiez pas merci monsieur le
président c'est beaucoup mieux
dams et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur vous avez raison c'est une
compétence des départements mais c'est
en réalité une compétence partagée et
c'est peut-être ça que l'état a un peu
oublié ces trente dernières années alors
oui il ya sa stratégie de prévention et
de protection de l'enfance que j'ai
annoncée en octobre dernier qui contient
une partie contractualisation avec des
avec des moyens supplémentaires je vais
y revenir mais il ya aussi tout un
ensemble de mesures nationales qui
permettent d'avoir une approche un
pilotage renforcé de cette politique un
pilotage une fois encore partagés l'état
doit aussi être au rendez vous de ses
propres conséquents compétences quand il
s'agit d'éducation quand il s'agit de
santé par exemple c'est la raison pour
laquelle je veut réformer le pilotage et
la protection de l'enfance c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai demandé à la
haute autorité de santé d'établir un
référentiel sur l'évaluation des
situations de danger pour les enfants
pour qu'un enfant de soir
aujourd'hui un enfant n'est pas en
danger de la même façon qu'ils se
trouvent à lille ou à marseille c'est
absolument incompréhensible c'est la
raison pour laquelle encore j'ai demandé
au conseil national et la protection de
l'enfance d'établir des taux
d'encadrement nationaux pour les
établissements dans lesquels se trouvent
nos enfants et puis à la dimension
contractualisation j'ai effectivement
proposé aux départements de
contractualiser avec l'état cette
proposition est le fruit d'une
concertation de trois mois qui a associé
l'ensemble des parties et avec deux
obligations pour les départements de
soumettre des projets de
réinvestissement dans la protection
maternelle et infantile
car je crois beaucoup en la prévention
et la nécessité d'investir davantage
dans la prévention est par ailleurs de
nous faire remonter des projets pour
prendre en charge les enfants en
situation de handicap car les enfants en
situation de handicap dans notre pays
sont au croisement du social et du
médico-social et dans un pays qui aime
fonctionner en silo il se trouve qu'il
tombe dans le trou qui se trouve entre
les deux soixante deux départements ont
répondu favorablement à la proposition
que je leur faisais 30 d'entre eux ont
été sélectionnés d'ici au 1er juillet 30
contrat individualisé territorialisée
vont être réalisés et d'ici au 1er
juillet nous sélectionnerons également
les 30 prochains département afin que la
mise en oeuvre de cette
contractualisation pour ses trente
départements supplémentaires avec les
fonds qui rompt avec puisse être
effectif à partir du 1er janvier 2021
que celui la parole est maintenant notre
collègue brigitte lherbier pour le
groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
le ministre de l'ancien entre
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
madame le ministre depuis plus de trois
mois des universitaires sont en grève en
france c'est le cas par exemple à
l'université de lille où certains
enseignants n'assurent pas leurs cours
depuis le 5 décembre
ces enseignants ne sont pas astreints
déclarer leur grève qui paralyse le
fonctionnement de l'université
la liste de leurs revendications et sans
fin même si la baisse des crédits
consacrés aux laboratoires de recherche
apparaît être le détonateur de leur
mouvement de contestation
ce sont les étudiants qui n'ont plus de
cours depuis plusieurs mois qu'ils m'ont
alertée je sais à l'heure qu'il est que
les étudiants ce sont à la fois inquiet
et en colère parce qu'ils ne sont plus
en mesure de recevoir l'enseignement
pour lequel ils se sont inscrits à
l'université
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer quelques
uns ici présents dans le public
d'autres collègues ont eu les mêmes
retour ces mouvements se répète au sein
de nos universités au détriment de la
formation de nos jeunes
la situation de l'enseignement supérieur
est particulièrement préoccupante
année après année nos universités ne
cesse de reculer au sein des grands
classements internationaux
si rien n'est fait les inégalités vont
vont encore s'accroître entre les
étudiants
il y a ceux qui iront étudier dans les
grandes écoles ou à l'étranger et les
autres nos étudiants tous le droit à un
enseignement supérieur de qualité bien
sûr le niveau des examens finaux
s'adaptera au programme réellement
étudié par les étudiants mais accéder au
concours nationaux leur sera très
difficile voire inaccessible
l'ascenseur social qui était l'essence
même de lui
diversité ne peut pas fonctionner dans
de telles conditions madame le ministre
quelle est la position du gouvernement
que l'on a peu entendu sur le sujet avez
vous quelque chose à dire aux étudiants
qui sont privés de cours depuis quelques
temps pour vous répondre
la parole est à la milice de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et l'innovation
voilà un frédéric vidal madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice lherbier
les situations que vous décrivez
existent elles sont heureusement
extrêmement minoritaire et il appartient
bien sûr au responsable des
enseignements responsable des formations
aux présidents d'université et bien de
faire en sorte que ces situations n'ait
pas lieu
ces situations sont observées dans un
petit nombre d'universités mais ce que
l'on observe aussi de plus souvent de
plus en plus souvent dans nos
universités
c'est effectivement le fait que les
étudiants font entendre leur voix et ça
a été le cas pas plus tard qu'avant-hier
lors d'une assemblée générale au centre
casse un centre de l'université panthéon
sorbonne où les étudiants ont voté cette
fois ci à la majorité
le fait que les cours devaient reprendre
il a une forme de prise en otage des
étudiants par certains un nombre une
fois de plus minoritaire des enseignants
qui refusent de faire court c'est leur
droit le plus strict dans ce cas là ils
doivent évidemment se déclarer en grève
et il est important néanmoins que la
continuité de l'enseignement puisse être
assurée au sein des universités
à ce jour nous déplorons effectivement
un blocage qui perdure depuis quelques
semaines à l'université paul valéry est
effectivement dans quelques formations
de l'université de lille
je suis en lien permanent avec les
présidents d'universités qui essayent de
résoudre ce problème une fois de plus je
tiens à dire que la situation est
extrêmement compliqué pour ces étudiants
qui effectivement sont privés de leur
enseignement au détriment de leur
formation au détriment de l'importance
qu'ils y accorde et je crois que c'est
l'honneur
la très grande majorité des enseignants
chercheurs dans les universités de
veiller à ce que ces enseignements
puisse continuer à avoir lieu c'est pour
cela que nous avons mis en place le plan
étudiants plus d'un milliard d'euros
dans les universités sur la durée du
quinquennat et que nous réparons la loi
de programmation pour la recherche qui
valorisera l'ensemble des activités des
chercheurs et des enseignants-chercheurs
dans notre pays la parole est à l'autre
collègue andré vallini pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président
l'inconvénient de passer en fin de
séance et que la question que peut on
souhaiter aborder a déjà été largement
évoquée par mes collègues bargeton
benbassa buffet cigolotti et puis il ya
quelques minutes par monsieur del
picchia est justement monsieur le
ministre le drian vous avez dit que vous
avez une conversation privilégié avec
monsieur epica depuis quelques années
sur le sujet de la turquie
alors permettez-moi de m'immiscer dans
cette conversation et de vous poser la
question de l'appartenance de la turquie
à l'otan la turquie est membre de l'otan
or depuis quelques mois la turquie à
acheter des missiles russes plutôt
qu'occidentaux la turquie a attaqué les
kurdes nos alliés contre l'état
islamique sans prévenir
les alliés occidentaux la turquie vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure un terrien
libye en dehors de tout accord
international est depuis quelques jours
la turquie fait du chantage
vous l'avez dit aussi à l'égard de ses
alliés occidentaux d'europe occidentale
notamment
alors pour toutes ces raisons la
question doit se poser de l'appartenance
de la turquie à l'otan il ya quelques
mois le président de macron a dit que
l'otan était en état de mort cérébrale
est ce que le moment n'est pas venu de
provoquer un choc un électrochoc au sein
de l'otan et de poser la question de
l'appartenance de la turquie à
l'alliance atlantique
pour vous répondre par des communistes
de l'europe les affaires étrangères
monsieur l'ouvrier en avez la parole
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur vallini bienvenue au club de la
conversation sur la turquie
vous avez raison de souligner ses
ambiguïtés j'en ai relevé quatre au
moins
d'abord comme vous l'avez rappelé en
octobre dernier la turquie mais d'une
intervention unilatérale contre nos
alliés kurdes dans le cas de la
coalition contre des dons est membre
l'otan dont elle même fait partie
première ambiguïté
par ailleurs la turquie a décidé
unilatéralement de délimiter des zones
maritimes de juridiction propre en
contradiction avec le droit de la mer
bon nous le contestons mais en plus elle
mène des manoeuvres militaires contre un
autre pays membre de la même alliance
quelle la grèce en attendant d'autres
acteurs j'espère pas nous 3e 2e
ambiguïté troisième ambiguïté la turquie
vient de demander un soutien militaire
et des mesures de réassurance dans le
domaine de la défense aérienne et de la
défense antimissile et dans le même
temps elle vient de demander à l'otan et
dans le même temps elle achète du
matériel s 400 à la russie dont
l'interopérabilité au sein de l'otan
n'est pas avéré au contraire troisième
ambiguïté quatrième ambiguïté quand
elles se trouvent attaqués à idlib alors
la turquie se retourne vers l'otan en
disant je veux l'application de
l'article 4 qui demande la solidarité
des alliés j'ai pas l'article 5
l'article 4 il faut ouvrir des
conversations nous ouvrons les
conversations nous disons oui vous êtes
dans l'alliance l'article 4 s'applique
nous ouvrons des conversations mais dans
le même temps la turquie instrumentalisé
avec cynisme
les migrants j'ai évoqué cela tout à
leur quatrième ambiguïté alors oui
monsieur le sénateur la grande
explication s'impose elle s'impose dans
nos relations nous avec la turquie mais
elle s'impose aussi au sein de
l'alliance le président la république a
demandé à ce qu'il y ait une réflexion
stratégique de
le temps qu'ils soient mises à l'oeuvre
eh bien je crois que ça fait partie de
cette discussion cheval ailé merci de
votre réponse monsieur le ministre c'est
ambiguïté comme vous dites sont
maintenant insupportable c'est une
duplicité totale dont fait preuve le
prison erdogan et on peut plus supporter
cette ce comportement totalement
contraire aux engagements qui nous lient
au sein de l'alliance atlantique
merci la parole est à madame herzog dont
la réunion administrative et chez
blatter mais figurant sur la liste aucun
gros vous avez la parole
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur le ministre les
agriculteurs les collaborateurs
d'exploitation et les aides familiaux
ont besoin d'une réponse précise de
votre part sur l'avenir de leur retraite
actuellement la pension moyenne après
une carrière complète est de 740 euros
par mois pour un agriculteur et de 550
euros pour leurs conjoints
collaborateurs en avril 2019 le
président avait annoncé lui même que la
réforme des retraites permettrait aux
agriculteurs d'avoir un minimum de 1000
euros nous avions tous saluent à
l'époque cette mesure très attendue que
le sénat avait d'ailleurs des avait
d'ailleurs défendu en mai 2018 le
gouvernement la valeur refusé en nous
expliquant qu'elle sera intégrée à la
future réforme
qu'en est il aujourd'hui et bien
aujourd'hui nous apprenons finalement
que cette retraite minimum concernera
uniquement ceux qui ont cotisé tout au
long de leur carrière comme chef
d'exploitation du minerai au niveau du
smig un mode de calcul qui dans les
faits va exclure les trois quarts des
retraites concernés et particulièrement
les femmes d'agriculteurs
de plus cette mesure ne sera appliquée
qu'en 2022 laissant les retraités
actuels de la précarité que nous
connaissons déjà
enfin nous apprenons maintenant que ni
les 1000 euros
ni les 85% du smic promis de sont
inscrits dans la loi et qu'ils feront
l'objet d'un décret et pour répondre aux
inquiétudes des agriculteurs et des élus
le ministre de la santé a annoncé ici
même qu'une mission parlementaire ferait
des propositions à l'automne prochain
ce n'est pas la réponse que nous
attendons donc la situation est connue
depuis longtemps et son niveau d'urgence
l'est également
je vous demande donc monsieur le
ministre 2 vous nous dire clairement qu
montre comment votre réforme va
améliorer le sort des agriculteurs pour
ces différentes catégories parole et à
monsieur didier guillot ministre de
l'agriculture que le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
votre question est très importante et je
vais répondre oui
et merci de l'avoir posée vous
interrogez vous vous interrogez sur les
85% les 1000 euros
vous dites que ce n'est pas dans la
réforme des retraites c'est dans la
réforme des retraites
d'ailleurs les agriculteurs font partie
de ceux qui gagneront à 100% dès 2022
d2d 2022
dès 2022 une pension minimum d'une
pension minimale de 1000 euros pour
toutes les cultures qui ont une carrière
complète qui montrera bien sûr qui
montrera à 85% du smic
dès 2025 ensuite vous posez la question
à la fois des futures retraites et des
retraités actuels ne vont pas régler la
recette dans ce projet de loi que d'un
projet de loi une réforme universel par
répartition qui améliorera le sort de
tous les futurs agriculteurs à partir au
traité à partir de 2022 et 2025
on peut pas régler dans le même texte de
loi les quarante ans qui viennent et
réparer les errements des quarante ans
passés
c'est la raison pour laquelle
les cdc ce dont on parle c'est ce dont
on parle c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs pour la
première fois pour la première fois sous
tous les gouvernements pour la première
fois le premier ministre s'est engagé le
olivier veyrat on a parlé ici même de
mettre en place une un groupe de travail
est le président
et le président de la république
l'annoncé au dernier salon de
l'agriculture
neil les deux précédents gouvernements
ne se sent pas occupée des retraités
actuels et la situation était la même
zéro donc nous allons le faire dès
l'année prochaine et de le groupe de
travail devant rendre ses propositions à
monsieur le premier ministre
un amerloque quelques secondes merci
monsieur le ministre cette question est
trop important pour être portés nouvelle
fois nous avons la responsabilité de
donner des réponses précises sans
enfants attendent le futur décret et
ordonnance ou projet de loi merci en
avons terminé avec avec question
prochaines séances le mercredi 25 mars
j'ai bien noté 25 mars monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres devaient suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
quatre conventions internationales
examinée selon la procédure d'examen
simplifié notre séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
savez pu suivre en intégralité sur notre
antenne une séance marquée au tout début
par deux passes d'armes sur le dossier
des retraites ou edouard philippe a dû
répondre par deux fois pris en tenaille
1 par deux présidents de groupe
patrick kanner pour les socialistes et
bruno retailleau pour les républicains
patrick anr à dénoncer les faux pas les
erreurs les coups de menton du
gouvernement quand bruno retailleau a
quant à lui accusé edouard philippe de
se moquer des français faute de pouvoir
en discuter entre parlementaires du
financement tant que les partenaires
sociaux en sont chargés ils ont tous
deux dans une alliance gauche-droite
réclamé le report de l'examen
ici au sénat de deux semaines comme
gérard larcher l'a demandé au premier
ministre
et pour la première fois edouard
philippe a laissé cette porte ouverte le
premier ministre qui a évoqué une
discussion à ce sujet avec le président
gérard larcher il pose une seule
condition que cela n'empêche pas
l'adoption du texte d'ici l'été charge
maintenant à marc fesneau en charge des
relations avec le parlement de concilier
ses positions autre sujet largement
évoqués ici aujourd'hui la crise
migratoire à la frontière gréco turque
jean yves le drian sans s'avancer sur
des dispositifs apprécié et a appelé à
la solidarité européenne avec la grèce
demandant vigoureusement dénonçant
pardon vigoureusement le revirement de
la turquie je vous propose de l'écouter
cette pression migratoire elle est
organisée
elle est organisée par le régime du
président erdogan pour constituer un
élément de chantage à l'égard de l'union
européenne l'union européenne ne cédera
pas ce chantage nous avons décidé
d'organiser cet après midi cet après
midi une réunion des ministres de
l'intérieur de l'union européenne demain
je me rendrai à zagreb avec mes
collègues européens pour envisager
ensemble comment est-ce que l'on peut
concrètement aider la grèce aujourd'hui
dans cette situation particulièrement
difficile
enfin autre sujet très largement évoqué
le coronavirus ses conséquences sur
l'économie française notamment
mais ce qu'on le retiendra c'est une
passe d'armes assez surprenante sur ce
sujet plutôt consensuel passe d'armes
entre jérôme bascher sénateurs les
républicains de l'oise et laurent nunez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur jérôme bascher s'est
interrogé sur l'insuffisance des mesures
prises dans son département et sur le
risque que le risque que fait peser ce
virus sur les élections municipales
laurent nunez lui a répondu sèchement
dénonçant le fait que jérôme bascher
aurait brisé l'union sacrée sur le sujet
voilà tam pour les temps forts qui ont
marre c'est marqué cette question de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup géromin pour toutes ces
explications et nous allons et bien
poursuivre décryptage de cette question
d'actualité au gouvernement sur ce
plateau avec charlène bezina merci
d'être resté avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes constitutionnaliste et maître
de conférences à l'université de rouen
également sur ce plateau le sénateur la
république en marge de l'isère didier
rambaud bonjour également avec nous
françoise gatel vous êtes sénatrice us
c'est d'ille et vilaine et enfin sur ce
plateau bernard jomier sénateurs
socialistes
enfin au groupe socialiste de paris
center écologistes et au groupe
socialiste ici au sénat on va l'avoir
bien parler effectivement de cette
thématique cette thématique du
coronavirus bien argelier je précise que
vous êtes également un médecin vous avez
toujours votre cabinet dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris pour le croire
voilà voilà pour la publicité
que pensez-vous de la de l'action du
gouvernement contre le coronavirus
actuellement on a entendu un cette
polémique qui est monté dans l'hémicycle
où jérôme bascher sénateur de l'oise
et puis n'était pas le seul élu de loi
ce qui a beaucoup critiqué et bien la
politique du gouvernement qui a parlé
même d'impréparation non globalement
c'est difficile de faire face à une
épidémie comme ça dont on sait qu'elle
va progresser on ne peut plus l'arrêter
il faut pas raconter d'histoires quoi
c'est pour dans quelques il y aura des
milliers de cas il y aura quelques
dizaines de décès dans notre pays on
n'espère pas plus globalement le
gouvernement prend les mesures avec
quelques réserves
est-ce que les hôpitaux ou réellement
les moyens je ne crois pas ils sont en
grande difficulté
déjà au quotidien même si le ministre a
annoncé 260 millions de crédits
supplémentaires
il faut qu'ils arrivent deuxièmement les
professionnels de ville
il a fallu beaucoup trop de temps pour
qu'il reçoive des masques et
troisièmement les élus locaux sont
encore face à un certain nombre
d'incertitudes mais globalement je crois
qu'il faut contribuer positivement à
l'action du gouvernement et pas la
critiquer avec aussi cette réserve que
laurence rossignol appose a soulevé
serre que ce qui se passe sur la base de
creil relais visiblement plus du secret
défense que de la gestion sanitaire
oui effectivement à saint nombre de cas
qu'elle veut un cluster en fait la belle
de creil dans l'oise lithaire qui aura
cours accompagne rapatrier nos qu'on
laisse carrément évidemment les bonnes
mesures n'ont pas été prises
est ce que vous partagez ces inquiétudes
françoise gatel votre collègue tout à
l'heure jérôme bâtard également soulevé
des inquiétudes sur les élections
municipales il est allé jusque là ou
alors moi je pense je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec mon collègue il faut
prendre les choses sérieusement et en
même temps il faut sans doute savoir
raison garder et la chose est difficile
à gérer parce que trop de mesures
ce sera critique est passé de mesures ce
sera en tout cas aujourd'hui il faut
qu'ils aient vraiment un dialogue avec
les élus locaux qui ont à organiser les
élections municipales avec beaucoup de
questions de la part des assesseurs des
gens est-ce qu'il va falloir se laver
les mains est ce qu'il va y avoir des
gants etc
donc il faut rassurer les élus locaux
très rapidement par les préfectures
et s'il ya besoin de 2,2 gel s'il ya
besoin de gand folle et fournir aux élus
locaux je sais que l'exercice est
difficile mais ça contribuera à calmer
l'inquiétude de deux personnes qui
commencent à avoir peur voilà donc il
faut vraiment avoir cette information
cette transparence qu'une gouvernement a
mais maintenant il faut la voir avec les
élus locaux
oui didier rambaud est ce que le niveau
de transparence est au rendez-vous le
niveau d'information et un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont soulevé
qu'il y avait des mesures qui paraissent
pas forcément cohérente dans les
interdits
on de certains rassemblements etc en
tout cas c'est clair que nous nous
vivons une crise sanitaire que notre
pays doit faire preuve d'unité nationale
à face à un tel un tel problème
je salue le jeune entend de la part de
mes deux collègues parlementaires
je pense à un moment des plus c'est pour
ça que j'ai trouvé tout à l'heure la
question du collègue pas cher un petit
peu déplacé d'ailleurs il n'a pas été
très applaudie par par son groupe
mais je dirais que d'une manière
générale j'ai envie de dire aussi ça me
fait réagir sans gêne man 2 nous
laissant pas non plus contaminés par un
discours catastrophique
j'avoue que je n'apprécie pas trop un
petit peu cette forme de compteurs
combat au quotidien
le nombre de deux cas découvert le
nombre de morts qui étaient à bord
n'oublions pas qu'aujourd'hui tous les
jours malheureusement des gens mais
attention à ne pas trop à alimenter la
psychose essentielles nécessaires
et bien justement nous allons à nous
rendre salle des conférences puisque et
bien cela pose aussi des difficultés au
niveau économique et steve vous êtes
justement avec la secrétaire d'état anya
ce panier rennais qui a été interrogé
sur ces sujets oui madame la ministre
bonjour la chine est quasiment paralysée
on parle déjà de récession est ce que la
france va lui emboîter le pas non
d'abord la chine a redémarré donc
attention alors ne pas rester dans la
vision qu'on en avait dit ya deux
semaines ils ont redémarré ils ont plus
de 50% des sites qui sont aujourd'hui en
production et ils sont en train de
monter en puissance lentement vous avez
complètement raison et surtout la région
du houran reste dans un démarrage très
est décalé dans le temps par rapport à
ce qu'on espérait pour la france il ya
trois ans je le premier enjeu c'est
l'impact sur le chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises qui sont exposées à la chine
le deuxième enjeu c'est l'impact des
entreprises qui sont exposées en france
à la clientèle chinoise je pense au
tourisme évidemment aux entreprises du
luxe à l'événementiel et qui sont plus
largement exposée à la clientèle
internationale qui va - venir en france
parce que les déplacements
provenant d'italie provenant de corée du
sud provenant du japon qui sont des pays
aujourd'hui très touchés sont fortement
diminués et la troisième chose c'est les
chaînes de production
c'est à dire vous avez pour fabriquer un
panneau de porte de voiture
une pièce de moteur d'un avion une
petite pièce comme ça qui vient de chine
il faut que cette pièce soit livré dans
les temps de la production alors
concrètement comment on veut alors
aujourd'hui nous avons avec toutes les
filières industrielles fait à plusieurs
reprises le point nous sommes en contact
continu pour savoir si elle anticipe les
ruptures ce n'est pas le cas pour le
moment
et comment gérer éventuellement ce qu'on
appelle un double sourcing c'est à dire
d'aller chercher chez d'autres
fournisseurs les pièces qui pourraient
manquer ou gérer le stock
nous leur avons autorisé des mesures de
chômage partiel si elles perdent des
commandes ou inversement des mesures
facilitant les heures supplémentaires si
elles doivent accélérer leur commande
parce qu'elles ont des livraisons un peu
décalé dans le temps pour rattraper le
temps perdu alors est par ailleurs en
termes de trésorerie ce qui est vraiment
le nerf de la guerre pour les
entreprises du report d'échéances
fiscales et sociales pour toutes les
entreprises qui en font la demande de
façon à ce qu'elles récupèrent de la
trésorerie
nous avons également demandé à bp il
augmentait ses garanties sur sur les
entreprises justement la fed a revu ses
intérêts à la baisse pour lutter contre
les conséquences du coronavirus ça vous
donne des idées il faut soutenir la
demande il faut soutenir l'activité
c'était des décisions qui doivent être
prises au niveau de l'europe
la banque centrale européenne travaille
bruno le maire a eu un long entretien
avec christine lagarde mardi nous avons
des réponses qui sont adaptées au niveau
du g7 au niveau de l'eurogroupe
bruno le maire a d'ailleurs eu là encore
un entretien tout à l'heure avec
l'ensemble de ses homologues européens
donc on saura prendre les mesures je
manquais la présidente de la commission
européenne l'a indiqué mais à ce stade
la première mesure c'est celle que nous
avons prise c'est celle de redonner de
la trésorerie aux entreprises
elle ne demande pas plus et elles
doivent être accompagnées et c'est ce
que nous faisons
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
d'avoir répondu aux questions de public
sénat on va tout de suite accueillir
monsieur marc fesneau
juste la voilà bonjour monsieur le jour
bonjour monsieur le ministre le 49-3 a
donc été enclenchée à l'assemblée
nationale une bataille a été remportée
vous attendez à la guerre ici au sénat
mais c'est faux pas employer des mots
comme ça quand on est en démocratie les
unit bataille ni guerre il ya des débats
il ya des confrontations et des points
de vue différents qui s'exprime
essayons nous mêmes que nous sommes
responsables politiques de ne pas
employer les mots de la guerre quand ce
n'est pas la guerre la politique ce
n'est pas la guerre la politique c'est
le débat c'est la confrontation d'idées
c'est la confrontation de points de vue
c'est aussi la capacité à trouver des
consensus et c'est dans ce cadre là avec
cette volonté là que nous avons abordé
le débat à l'assemblée nationale parce
que nous n'avons pas fait de manoeuvres
d'obstruction nous avons voulu le débat
et nous avons fait preuve de pendant
quinze jours de la volonté que nous
avions de faire le débat d'autres ont
voulu employer les méthodes de
l'obstruction les méthodes un peu de la
guérilla pour le coup ils ont les choses
comme elles sont donc on a pris les
responsabilités qui étaient nécessaires
pour que nous sortions comme c'est prévu
par le 49-3 premier ministre a rappelé
les mots de michel debré sur le
dispositif en disant que c'était aussi
un dispositif qui était pour empêcher
les manoeuvres on était bien dans des
dispositions mano et donc on va
travailler désormais à la lecture de ce
texte la première lecture de ce texte ou
sénat vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit le
premier ministre et la volonté que nous
avons d'essayer de trouver avec le
président du sénat avec le sénat les
voies d'un dialogue et d'un débat qui
soit serein et qui soit conforme la
décision grâce de notre report de
l'examen des textes vous avez entendu
précisément ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre donc c'était il ya donc un
quart d'heure oui et donc on va regarder
avec le président du sénat vous
permettait en garde les étapes dans
l'ordre il faut les prendre on va t on
va regarder tranquillement avec le
président du sénat je j'ai bien lu ce
que demandait le président du sénat et
les groupes du sénat j'ai vous avez bien
entendu ce qu'a dit aussi le problème ni
sur la nécessité du calendrier pour
qu'une fois le texte voté et puis se
mettre en oeuvre dans des conditions qui
soient des conditions claires des
conditions faisable de mise en oeuvre du
texte est bien c'est de chacun sait ce
que sont les attentes des autres dans
ces cas là on va se mettre autour de la
table et essayer d'y travailler
le projet de loi organique va être
examiné à l'assemblée vient de démarrer
à l'assemblée nationale marc et vous
attendez quoi de l'obstruction
parlementaire encore
j'espère qu'il n'y en aura pas je ne
m'attends à plus rien on verra on actera
ce que sont les positions des uns des
autres mais notre volonté c'est que on
essaie de trouver quand même les voies
d'un débat qui n'a pas pu avoir lieu sur
le texte ordinaire quand est ce que vous
allez rencontrer gérard larcher rats et
puis ça n'a pas lieu d'avoir une
promotion particulière le président m'a
chargé de dénouer ce dialogue qui
continue avec le sénat et nous
entretenons le premier cela rappelait
des relations je crois assez franche
avec la présidence du sénat avec le
sénat c'est bien qu'on puisse se dire
les choses et qu'on essaie de trouver
quand c'est possible des compromis on
verra on va regarder les choses le
gouvernement est à la disposition du
sénat comme de la noce semblait
nationale pour essayer de trouver les
choses donc on va regarder dans les
jours qui viennent
quel compromis concrètement peu de
talent et pardon de vous dire que ce
n'est pas avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour public sénat sur un plateau de télé
visées de télévision que les choses se
font c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne
non mais on peut peut-être avoir
quelques pistes mais vous aurez les
pistes quand il y aura les pistes et on
va se mettre au travail et non mais
excusez moi vous avez une façon de poser
des questions je veux pas être
désagréable
on va travailler avec la présidence du
sénat on va travailler avec les groupes
du sénat permettait que je réserve que
nous réservions ce dialogue là entre
nous et si vous mourez invité je
viendrais volontiers je reviendrai
volontiers vous dire ce que sont le
résultat de nos travaux et j'espère
qu'ils seront positifs et on attend ça
avec impatience mermoz ig merci monsieur
le ministre c'est à vous tous merci
beaucoup et steve pour cette interview à
écouter vous avez posé toutes les
questions que vous pouviez vous n'aurez
pas la réponse est pourtant on attend
avec impatience un il faut le dire un
challenge bezina effectivement cette
demande de report de 15 jours sur le
débat parlementaire pour avoir les
résultats de la conférence de
financement il faut dire que j'aurais à
l'arche ils demandent depuis le début de
l'année c'était l'objet de sa première
conférence de presse de rentrée au mois
de janvier
en effet et on peut dire aussi que c'est
une logique qui est tout à fait
parlementaires tout à fait saine on
incite le parlement à financer les
projets qui sont les siens les
propositions qui sont les siennes sur
tous les projets le parlement est incité
à essayer de faire de la meilleure
gestion et là c'est quand même le projet
phare la mère de toutes les réformes
pour prendre
seulement le mount bruno retailleau qui
l'a elle est présentée sans son
financement donc on a le sentiment
d'avoir qu'une seule partie du projet
une espèce de coquilles vides et le
parlement a besoin de tous les moyens
pour pouvoir être correctement informés
et mener le débat qui est sa mission
fondamentale donc on peut totalement
comprendre cette demande de délai je
pense pas que il y ait quelque chose
d'absolument intenable dans ce qui a été
demandé dans le sens où il ya en plus
les municipales qui a reste au milieu
donc yaya quand même du fond à cette
question françoise gatel le premier
ministre alors il n'a pas fermé la porte
wilairot si vous avez interprété
toutefois les voies les voix du premier
ministre reste encore à peu à penne
table et on le voit après le discours de
marc raynaud en même temps moi
sincèrement je lis je pense que
politiquement le gouvernement intérêt à
entendre la question qui est posée par
le sénat et pas par rapport au sénat
mais pour refaire un peu l'histoire de
cette réforme
on a une réforme qui a priori pouvait
séduire beaucoup de français une réforme
enfin une retraite plus juste un régime
par répartition pérenniser et la fin des
régimes spéciaux puis au fur à mesure du
temps c'est devenu un peu plus brouillon
un clair on ne savait plus et ça a
généré de l'attention de la part de gens
qui poursuivre d'autres objectifs que
celui de la retraite et de l'inquiétude
et de l'incertitude c'est des gens qui
ont un peu peur et l'incertitude dans
l'opinion voilà et voici mais moi j'aime
bien la forme de doute et ça paraît
tellement incompréhensible que j'en dise
on n'en veut pas on a peur et donc
aujourd'hui en disant ben moi j'accepte
que le sénat ait un peu plus de temps
puisque le calendrier que propose le
président du sénat c'est pas beau
embêter le monde c'est parce qu'il est
concomitant avec la fin de la conférence
de deux films ans une association et que
qui pourrait comprendre qu'on refuse au
sénat de bénéficier d'informations dont
l'assemblée n'a pas eu donc moi je
trouve que ce serait apaisant et ça
montreuil que le gouvernement il est
dans un dialogue comme nadine ministre
fait nos très franc avec le sénat
justement on va écouter à la réponse qui
a eu tout à l'heure le premier ministre
edouard philippe sur ce sujet exactement
et puis on revient en plateau pour en
part
le président du ces dames a adressé un
courrier qui traitent du même sujet que
celui que vous évoquez j'ai eu
l'occasion de lui dire à l'occasion d'un
contact téléphonique monsieur le
président cela vous m'autorisez à faire
état de ce contact téléphonique
je vous en remercie j'ai merci téléphone
mais les yeux dans les yeux
[Musique]
e
à une époque à une époque où les
contacts physiques sont plus compliquées
cette forme de tendresse me touche
également monsieur le président que bref
tout ça pour dire monsieur le président
caennais que nous voulons faire en sorte
que ce projet de loi soit adopté avant
l'été
j'ai indiqué au ministre des relations
avec le parlement qu'il lui appartenait
de se rapprocher du président du sénat
pour voir dans quelles conditions nous
étions en mesure à la fois de faire en
sorte que la discussion parlementaire au
sénat s'effectue comme nous l'espérons
tous dans d'excellentes conditions et de
garantir que l'objectif que je me suis
fixé d'une adoption avant l'été soit
atteint cette discussion a lieu dans les
heures dans les jours qui viennent
avec évidemment toute la qualité des
relations que nous entretenons avec le
président du sénat je vous remercie et
didier rambaud on vient d'entendre donc
eh bien cette porte qui n'est pas fermée
hier par le premier ministre à cette
demande de report est ce que vous vous
souhaitez et bien qu'il puisse y avoir
ce report de 15 jours pour avoir les
conclusions de la conférence de
financement est ce que vous trouvez ça
légitime et m'écoutent et comme
parlementaire la république en marche
j'ai envie de vous dire oui pour chiche
alors j'ose espérer qu'il n'y a pas
d'arrière pensée dans la proposition du
président larcher à vous avez fait
allusion tout à l'heure à cette
conférence de presse de rentrée
ce jour là j'ai beaucoup plus entendu le
le chef de l'opposition que le président
national
on s'y habitue depuis deux ans 1 une
évolution de sa fonction c'est
parfaitement son droit mais on doit le
savoir demande politique faut le
craignais je suis d'accord avec vous
voilà il ya quand même un objectif qui
était affichée par le premier ministre
quand même de boucler ça avant là avant
le début de l'été
bon je pense que c'est jouable et
effectivement donc pourquoi pas
effectivement de d'anticiper de quelques
jours bernard jeu mais qu'est ce que ça
apporterait ses quinze jours
supplémentaires vous du côté du groupe
socialiste vous voulez aller quand même
plus loin dans les démarches
parlementaire vous vous demandez une
commission d' enquête sur notamment et
bien l'étude d'impact commission dont
quatre qui je le précise a été refusée à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui et la
retraite c'est quand même 15 à 20 ans la
vie des français et le système des
retraites
c'est ce qui produit leurs revenus
pendant ces quinze à vingt ans ils n'ont
pas d'autre source à cette période de la
vie et donc c'est un des fondements de
notre démocratie sociale et on ne
modifie pas en profondeur un fondement
de notre démocratie sociale quand il ya
60 % des français qui ne veulent pas
désolé mais ça ça n'est pas responsable
et on instaure pas le dialogue
de cette façon là alors la question
c'est pas de savoir si edouard philippe
va être gentil ou pas avec le sénat et
six à quinze jours de plus ou de moins
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on répond
aux français qui posent de multiples
questions et qui n'obtiennent pas de
réponse parce que le travail a été mal
préparée dans les conditions qu'on
connaît mal à mener l'étude d'impact du
conseil d'état extrêmement sévère la
conférence de financement n'est pas
clôturée c'est pour ça que ce que je dis
simplement c'est qu'il faut redonner du
temps au temps et c'est pas que ce soit
quinze jours ou six mois il faut prendre
le temps nécessaire non pas pour refuser
une réforme parce qu' il faudrait
refuser une réforme
on peut être d'accord sur des principes
de fond de cette réforme
mais on voit bien que tout
l'enchaînement est désastreux et ne
répondent pas au cul les préoccupations
des français quels objectifs de votre
demande de commission d'enquêté
parlementaire mais vous voyez bien que
la façon dont le conseil d'état sort une
étude d'impact qui est désastreuse pour
le gouvernement donc comment en est on
arrivé là
comment comment un haut commissaire est
nommé pendant deux ans il dit qu'il
travaille à préparer donc à mettre sur
la table les données et compris les
données financières et on arrive à une
étude d'impact du conseil d'état qui dit
qu'en gros à peu près rien n'est réglé
il faut comprendre comment on en est
arrivé
elle est extrêmement sévère en bois
n'est pas d'acord sévère faut pas
caricaturer n'ont plus battu rennes
bezina elle est quand même sévère 7
alors l'état c'est une étude d'impact
qui est une étude d'impact
gouvernementale le conseil d'état a
donné donc un avis sur l'étude d'impact
et sur l'ensemble du projet d'accord ce
sur quoi il a pointé en effet certaines
incohérences des des problèmes
d'intelligibilité lacunaire par lala
notamment salon un problème
d'articulation de relais dispositif
il faut savoir que ce qui est
intéressant aussi dans le rôle que le
sénat peut jouer au niveau de
l'opposition et pas uniquement à mon
avis est que la majorité va se servir de
ce débat et que ça serve l'opposition
sert aussi la majorité comme vous le
dites sur un sujet aussi important que
celui ci je crois que le débat apaisé
qui peut avoir lieu au sénat et le sénat
peut tirer son épingle du jeu de ce
moment parlementaire qui a été contrarié
à l'assemblée nationale l'idée c'est que
le sénat puisse avoir les moyens d'être
informés d'informer les français et de
sereinement reprendre un débat de fond
sur cette question mais c'est un moment
où le sénat peut jouer un rôle central
c'est ce qu'espèrent certains
parlementaires
françoise gatel vous pensez qu'on peut
avoir un vrai débat de fond mais
absolument enfin moi je pense que ce
texte est la situation dans laquelle on
est vous montrer encore une fois
l'intérêt à perm la pertinence du
bicamérisme et qu'ici il y aura
naturellement des oppositions et des
avis différents mais je pense qu'on sera
dans une dignité est vraiment dans on va
dire un combat parce que ce sera un
combat d'idées et de projets mais qui
n'aura rien à voir avec les séquences de
grand guignol qu'on a vu à l'assemblée
il faut les dénoncer
parce que ce qu'on a vu à l'assemblée se
sont pas des gens qui ont défendu un
projet
ce sont des gens qui n'ont qu'une envie
c'est vraiment de démonter le
gouvernement alors même que chacun sait
que la pérennité de notre système de
retraite n'est pas assurée et qu'il y a
un enjeu de solidarité nationale et
d'équité maintenant il faut que le
gouvernement arrive à retisser des liens
de confiance je crois que la retraite
elle se construit sur un contrat social
dans notre pays et je pense que le sénat
avec la capacité des différents partis à
s'affronter dignement et sur le fond
peuvent contribuer à
apaisé et non pas aller systématiquement
s'affronter au gouvernement mais à
remettre les choses à plat même si
chacun peut dire que c'est dommage que
ce calendrier législatif et été choisi
mais on est là aujourd'hui et on fait
quoi c'est chiant il ya quand même un
président qui a été élu sur un projet et
que moi je rappelle que quand on est
parlementaire
on a tous une responsabilité c'est de
défendre ses idées défendre un projet
mais plus que tout ya nos concitoyens et
ya la survie de ce pays et je
rappellerai juste de manière très
tranquille que comme le président de la
république a été élu qu'on ait voté pour
lui ou pas chacun n'avaient qu'un mot à
la bouche c'est le nom de marine le pen
avec la peur des extrémités bien
continuons à laisser la france insoumise
à faire ce qu'elle fait et demain
maintenant sera en grand danger donc il
faut se calmer se ressaisir et que le
gouvernement accepte que le sénat et des
idées un peu différente et à faire aussi
un bout de chemin des idées différentes
c'est sûr qu'il y en aura il y aura un
réel affrontement d'idées petit aperçu
tout à l'heure à 20 khz et bien
l'intervention la réplique tout à
l'heure de bruno retailleau qui lui
aussi interpellé premier ministre sur la
réforme des retraites
quinze jours nous vous demandons
monsieur le premier ministre et c'est
faux pour des millions de français la
date d'application c'est au moins 2037
vous ne réformez pas vous déformez notre
modèle social
je le dis devant mes collègues hisser au
sénat de la république ce que vous
apprêtez à faire ce n'est pas moderniser
notre sécurité sociale c'est a créé une
insécurité sociale pour des millions de
français qui seront perdants vous
baisserez les pensions vous allez vous
apprêtez à créer une sécurité sociale à
deux vitesses pour la majorité des
français d'un côté et pour ceux qui
gagnent plus de 3 plafond de la sécurité
sociale de l'autre à une véritable
opposition on le voit dans l'hémicyle
didier rambaud
vous vous apprêtez à créer une
insécurité sociale ajoutent à leur
interpellé le président du groupe elle m
j'espère que le le président rod ayew va
pas se comporter comme un un sénateur
français soumise un document comme on
l'a vu se trouve et quel est votre ex
ailleurs ensemble parler d'insécurité
parler de baisse des pensions va
effectivement je pense qu'il est il à
côté la plaque
moi j'avais dit reclus ce qui nous
rappelle son projet qui était plutôt
d'augmenter le départ à la retraite à
l'âge de
je pense que ça va être question pour le
sénat de rappeler de dire qu'il l'a voté
puisqu'il est certainement dans aveux
sous la torture l air à l'assemblée il
le préciser dans le vote depuis cadence
et berck où là je sais pas où
l'insécurité mais voilà la baisse des
tensions nourries justement l'objectif
c'est de pouvoir qui n'est plus de
pension inférieure à 1000 euros
c'est faire en sorte qu'aujourd'hui les
femmes qui ont des carrières hachées par
exemple ne soit pas obligé d'atteindre
d'atteindre l'âge de 67 ans pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
donc voilà je vais raoult et la sécurité
sociale en tout cas j'espère
effectivement que n'aura pas au sénat
mais je suis plutôt confiant ce qu'on a
vécu ce qu'on a vu à l'assemblée
nationale où une véritable opération de
sabotage a pu parlementaire notre
intérêt que des députés de l'opposition
qui se sont comportés
je reprends d'auteur que j'ai entendu ce
matin ici même sur ce bateau comme des
délinquants c'est pas normal qu
effectivement 4% des députés est
monopolisée 80% et des spas des débats
voilà donc effectivement je pense que le
sénat va peut-être retrouver son rôle de
serena d2 d'avoir un débat sur ce sujet
bernard jomier on en trouvait avait
utilisé les mots sabotage grand guignol
délinquants pour parlé tout à l'heure de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
tout ça ce sont des excès de langage
vous bien qu'ils en aient eu raison et
national on aimerait juste à l'excès on
n'est pas juge de nos collègues députés
je crois et c'est c'est aussi ça le
bicamérisme institutionnellement c'est
quand même très dur je leur dis de
penser que parce qu'on a été du chef de
l'état intentée dans un contexte que ma
collègue françoise gatel a rappelé
politique à votre contre marine le pen
parce qu on a 300 députés à l'assemblée
après on fait à peu près ce qu'on veut
en termes de réformes ça n'est pas ça
une démocratie sociale apaisée
ça n'est pas ça une démocratie au cou il
ya des corps intermédiaires où il y a
une opinion publique qui s'exprime et
encore une fois quand après un conflit
aussi long
après que beaucoup débat ait lieu 60 %
nos compatriotes dans toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion
et ça c'est à dire que la rue gouverne
mais il faut en tenir compte ne sont
contre ce système c'est au moins qu'ils
n'ont pas compris
alors il faut remettre les choses à plat
dans le calme moi je fais partie des
parlementaires qui ne sont pas l'imposer
en suisse par principe un système à
points mais il faut dire la valeur du
point qui a droit à quoi faudrait
voilà donc ce matin brutale que le
gouvernement malheureusement entretien
il faut sortir de cette logique et ce
matin le devant la commission des
affaires sociales instinct nombre
d'économistes du mans et 10 youn et
certains étaient complètement favorable
au principe de la réforme initialement
et ont dit toute leur critique toutes
leurs réserves
vient alors l'idée de choses à plat et
prendre le temps alors on va passer à
présent pour conclure cette émission au
dernier thème de cette émission car il a
aussi beaucoup été question de la crise
migratoire lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
plusieurs fois jean yves le drian a été
interpellé mais aussi le secrétaire
d'état laurent munier a écouté tout à
l'heure sa réponse était sa réponse à la
sénatrice esther benbassa la france dans
ce cadre là et notamment dans le cadre
des politiques menées par l'union
européenne est venue renforcer le
dispositif frontex et de la même façon
nous sommes venus renforcer la capacité
de traitement des demandes d'asile de la
grèce il y à un conseil des ministres de
l'intérieur qui se tient en ce moment
qui va se tenir à 17h sur ces sujets
puisque la grèce a demandé la solidarité
des autres pays européens des autres
états membres et donc le conseil va se
tenir tout à l'heure évidemment que la
politique de la france est le ministre
le de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères l'a rappelé évidemment que la
politique de la france aura une
politique de solidarité
françoise gatel évidemment que la
politique de la france sera une
politique de solidarité a dit laurent
d'élèves qui répondait pardon à françois
noël buffet néanmoins c'est une crise
qui est en train de mettre et bien en
test l'union européenne et puis aussi la
position de la france alors absolument
je lui on met en tête sans fin erdogan
oui mais on teste l'union européenne en
fait ils instrumentalisent la misère
humaine et la détresse des gens pour
contrer aujourd'hui poutine qui par le
soutien qu'ils apportent à d'autres
puissances mammal fameuse à cordes de
sotchi promener dans d alors j'emploie
pas à ce moment là mais on est dans des
stratégies géopolitiques très compliqué
au milieu de tout champ on a une
situation humanitaire qui est juste un
peu
sergio des hommes et des femmes qui sont
l'instrument de stratégie politique de
gens qui comme erdogan en plus ont un
contrat non seulement moral mais
financier avec l'europe puisque en
échange de 2 de la garde de ses
frontières l'europe lui donne des
financements donc il faut à la fois
gérer cette crise humanitaire
aujourd'hui mais il faut aussi que
l'europe parle d'une seule voix on ne
peut pas laisser les grecs cela ça il
faut vraiment montrer à un dogan qui ne
peut pas être le maître du jeu et qu' il
ne peut pas mettre au défi l'union
européenne pour gérer ses propres
difficultés donc c'est une crise
géopolitique je crois extrêmement grave
extrêmement sérieuse mais moi je suis
très heureuse de la détermination du
ministre des affaires étrangères dans
cette situation et j'espère vraiment
qu'il y aura une unité européenne parce
que tous les pays européens où la
crainte de tout ça and shine bizarre
tout à l'heure et bien on nous l on a
bien compris que la turquie a dit eh
bien oui nos frontières sont ouvertes et
d'autre part et bien le drian l'a répété
tout à la wii mais les frontières de la
grèce elles sont fermées
alors que fait-on de toutes ces
personnes qui sont en train d'affluer
des frontières turques et qui donc se
retrouve complètement coincés là sur
l'île de lesbos par exemple en au finish
moi je crois que c'est un double
discours c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
dire que il y aura de la solidarité et
qu'on aura de l'humanité pour gérer
cette crise là est précisé que à la
frontière de l'union européenne comme
par magie tout s'arrête sans aimer la
possible on parle vous l'avez dit d'être
humains d'hommes et de femmes d'enfants
qui sont dans des conditions on a parlé
tout à l'heure dans les réponses aux
questions jean yves le drian a parlé de
la détermination du secrétaire-général
de l'onu aussi sur les conditions dans
lesquelles les choses se passent à la
frontière syrienne mais même à la
frontière grecque enfin bon on a de plus
en plus de personnes qui affluent moi je
crois qu'on a ici affaire à un problème
d'une ampleur qui ne permettra pas
longtemps des discours politiques
d'arrangements et qu'il faut trouver une
solution commune c'est ce qu'ont rappelé
plusieurs sénateurs notamment en parlant
de la position de la turquie au sein de
l'otan
il y a des
arbitrage à reprendre à zéro didier
rambaud oui plusieurs sujets cette crise
que nous vivons défi migratoire vous
devons affirmer notre solidarité
vis-à-vis de la grèce l'europe doit
toile affirmé c'est un nouveau test
encore pur pour l'europe et c'est une
épreuve de vérité ont rappelé aussi à
notre communauté turque ce que le
président r dogan fictivement que la
manière dont il joue avec l'europe
rappelant qu'il ya tout le pays avec un
bénéficier de plus 2,6 milliards d'euros
1 2 milliard pour pouvoir gérer cette
première crise des migrants
et puis effectivement il la question de
la ion sein de l'alliance ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui la réelle place de la
turquie dans notre alliance
voilà c'est ce genre de défis devant
nous bernard jomier alors faut-il dans
ces circonstances c'est la question qu'a
posée tout à l'heure esther benbassa des
problèmes d des programmes d'accueil des
migrants de répartition au sein de
l'union européenne aussi c'était là la
question qu'elle posait
moi je crois qu'il faut une double
fermeté il faut une fermeté vis-à-vis du
président turc erdogan qui est un islamo
conservateur qui n'a absolument aucun
respect pour les droits humains et qui
démontre chaque jour qu'il est soit très
bien qu'il reste en dehors de l'europe
parce que nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs et la seconde fermeté c'est sur
nos valeurs humanitaires parce que la
situation en syrie épouvantable sont des
gens qui ont été bombardés gaz et depuis
des années qui ont vu tous leurs
environnements d'une vie ruinée et faut
que l'europe solidairement et comme elle
a su le faire beaucoup mieux en 2015 je
trouve l'impuissant d'angela merkel
assumer ont cessé à lui fermement et moi
je regrette les formules disons il faut
protéger nos frontières
oui mais il faut protéger aussi les gens
qui sont soumis à ces situations là il
ya un droit humanitaire international et
c'est notre grandeur aussi de le
respecter de l'appliquer oui didier
rambaud il a changé de discours sur ce
sujet emmanuel macron ça beaucoup
étaient pointés du doigt ils étaient sur
la même qu'au lac angela merkel vingt
ans maintenant
le de l'immigration en d'autres termes
de qualité voilà auquel il faut faire
face à la réalité de ses abonnés
l'abandonner s'est passé c'est non non
bien aussi c'est cette fameuse phrase je
regarde ta peau moitié de ces personnes
accusées toute la misère du accueillir
toute la misère est mort mais on doit il
prendre notre part voilà je pense canet
qui louera à trouver si jamais facile
mais ça renvoie aussi à la nécessité de
réfléchir à l'aide au développement
parce que je crois on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui affirmer avec tous nos
principes humanistes que l'on a les uns
et les autres qui peut s'engager à dire
nous accueillons tous ceux qui vont
devoir fuir leur part les situations de
guerre pas dans une situation de poids
économique
je sais bien mais en même temps on voit
bien comment des dirigeants
instrumentalise tout cela je crois qu'il
faut aussi savoir refuser
l'instrumentalisation
mais c'est un vrai chemin de crête et
qui est très difficile mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi qu'on reste ferme dans
l'intérêt même de tous ceux qui à un
moment seront condamnés à fuir leur pays
notamment pour des régions économiques
internationales le mot de la fin
le mot de la fin peut-être pour dire que
justement on voit à quel point ces
questions doivent être communes
on ne pourra pas s'en sortir dans le
cénacle des seuls états il faudra
nécessairement que ces questions
d'accueil et soient partagées déjà il
soit posée clairement tu valable encore
un nouveau défi pour l'union européenne
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ces épreuves des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette émission est très
bonne soirée sur public sénat sur les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement on
se retrouve dans trois semaines il ya
quinze jours d'interruption youtube
[Musique]